This is Jocko podcast number one 39 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I lived awhile on Corregidor aisle that Sun Baked God cursed land where bomb and
Shell made life a hell with def on every hand.
I got the thirst there of the cursed with no water to be had.
I heard men scream in hellish dreams and watched my friends go mad.
Tis No man's fault,
the water salt or that the food is gone.
The guns are manned by men full damned facing each new dawn.
And when our bones blend with the stones,
you'll hear the parents cry.
The men who owned these splinter bones,
we're not afraid to die
and that is a poem written on the back of a scrap of paper postmarked prisoner
of war mail.
March,
1943 the note was addressed to James D culp,
US Navy gunner's mate FirstClass via his wife from the Red Cross while he was in
a prisoner of war camp in Osaka,
Japan.
And the author is unknown so it wasn't written by James d called,
it was sent to James d culp.
The author is unknown but is assumed to be one of copes fellow prisoners that
was captured on the Philippine island of Corregidor
and
the fall of the Philippines in World War II resulted in an absolutely horrific
event that resulted in the deaths of thousands of American and Filipino service
members.
And there's not any great records of how many actually died
in this terrible situation,
but throughout the prisoner of war camps of the Japanese in World War II,
the death rate was about 40% it was a nightmare.
And this is,
this is about the Bataan death march.
And we've heard a little bit about what the Japanese did to prisoners of war in
World War II.
We read the forgotten Highlander by Alastar you cart,
and that was podcast number 12
and he didn't talk about the Bataan death march,
but today we're going to hear from someone that did
okay.
The Bataan Death March,
a guy by the name of James Bolek,
a young member of the Army Air Corps
who
suffered through that terrible situation and wrote a book about it.
The book is called US soldiers journal by James Bullock.
And let's get right into it.
Go into the book.
I joined the service August 23rd,
1940 at Barksdale field,
Shreveport,
Louisiana,
and was assigned to the 16th bomb squadron at 27th bomb group.
I joined because Paris had just fallen to the Germans and I felt we would soon
be at war.
I was in college at the time and just finished my third semester.
All the talk around school was about war and it was hard to keep my mind on
books.
I was attending southwestern Louisiana Institute in Lafayette through a
government program called the end.
Why?
Yay.
The National Youth Administration,
we received $30 a month and had to work a full eight hours every other day.
Because of this,
it was hard to schedule classes and hard to study properly from our $30 pay.
We had to put about $18 each month for Roman board,
which left $12 for other essential such as books,
paper,
pencils,
et cetera.
Because going to college was so difficult under these circumstances.
It seemed that the army could not be any worse,
so going to join the army.
I went home and told my parents what I plan to do.
My mother was horrified and strictly against it.
At the time.
I needed my parent's consent to join because of my age.
I was 19 my father agreed to sign and convinced my mother to sign.
Also,
I remember her saying that if anything happened to me,
she did not want to be blamed for letting me go in the army.
I was sworn in with the rest of the recruits.
I had a choice of joining a weather squadron or a bombardment squadron.
Of course,
I chose the bombardment squadron.
I did not join the army to study the weather.
I joined a fight.
That is what I thought.
I was therefore assigned to the 16th bomb squad and the 27th bomb group,
army clothes and equipment.
At this time,
we're in short supply and were not provided and we were not provided with
clothes,
et Cetera for quite some time.
Obviously,
my statement that I always make is I'm skipping big chunks of this book and
reading some of the highlights so you get the flow of the story before we get
into the meat of the book.
It's a,
it's a great book.
It's a relatively short read,
but it's a great book.
Back to the book,
the clothing we had was essentially still world war one.
We had leggings,
campaign hats,
et Cetera at this time,
and then he ends up going to a school to learn his skills about bombing.
Back to the book.
The school lasted about nine months and I came out knowing everything.
There was no about an airplane.
When school was over from my class.
I was offered a position as instructor of drafting,
but I turned it down.
I want to get back with my outfit and his outfit was down in Savannah.
When I got back to Savannah,
I found out my,
I found my outfit packing up to go on maneuvers in Louisiana.
Within a few days we were,
we were on our way by army truck.
At night.
We would stop,
set up our mess tent,
eat and hit the sack.
We slept on the ground under a pup tent.
It took us through two or three days to reach our final stop,
which was at the airfield at Lake Charles here.
We lived in tents again,
just as our first days in Savannah.
As far as I was concerned at the time,
maneuvers were a joke.
Instead of having actual machine guns,
antiaircraft,
guns,
foxholes,
et Cetera,
there were wooden signs all around to indicate these.
If the air raid siren went off,
we were supposed to run out to one of these signs.
The way that one of the maneuvers did apparently help us with down the line was
to adapt too hard,
rough outdoor living.
We were also on reduced rations,
which helped prepare us for what was to come.
Later on,
we would fly over the enemy and drop small sacks of flour on them.
Referees could tell if we hit or missed and the sides were scored accordingly.
I don't remember how long these maneuvers lasted,
but it seems like it was at least a month,
so they're out there.
I thought this was interesting because we do dumb stuff like that sometimes in
the military where,
well you think it's dumb,
but what you're really trying to do is get the broad muscle movements of a
military organization working.
So you say,
okay cause it's not easy to get 500 men assembled and move to a location that it
takes practice and so that they just run people through planning and training
exercises that you're just trying to get these broad muscle movements.
Even though for the troops on the ground sometimes I remember sometimes I'd be
thinking this is ridiculous,
this is so unrealistic.
But we weren't training the,
the front line troops,
what they were training was the logistics of this giant scenario.
So that's kind of what they're doing here.
Back to the book,
we finally got word to pack up and headed back home to Savannah.
We'd already gotten word that as soon as we reached Savannah we would need to
pack again this time to go overseas.
But no one knew where as yet.
So again,
Germany,
France had fallen to Germany or Paris would fall into Germany,
but we weren't in the war yet,
so this is pre World War II for America this time,
so he's just thinking he's going on a regular kind of deployment at this point.
Back to the book,
when he reached Savannah,
we found that most of our gear that we had left behind was already created and
ready to go.
As I recall,
in about a week or so,
we boarded the train for San Francisco.
All of our crates were stenciled with the letter letters,
p l u m plum,
but no one knew what it meant.
I should mention here that before we left Savannah,
I was called the first sergeant's office and told that I did not have to go
overseas if I did not want to.
Of course,
I immediately rejected the idea and it's that I definitely wanted to go to this
day.
I don't know why this came up because in talking to others in my outfit,
no one had had that opportunity
since I had applied for flight school.
It may be that I could have gone there,
so he had,
I didn't mention this part,
but he wanted to be a pilot so they could have been a possibility that they
wanted to send him a flight school.
But of course like many young 19 year old men,
what you want to do is you want to stick with your unit.
You want to go and fight and do.
At this point he's,
no,
he's fighting,
but he wants to go deploy with his guys.
Back to the book,
I still don't know what plums stood for,
but looking back now,
apparently the p stood for Philippines.
The l stood for the island of Luzon,
but the UNM,
I do not know that.
That's awesome.
Now they get to San Francisco eventually and here we go.
They're boarding the ship.
Back to the book,
the SS Coolidge was a lovely shipped that normally carried civilian passengers
to the Orient,
but now it was being used to transport troops.
We did not have state rooms but slept in corridors comparable to regular army
transports.
About the third day we found out where we were going up.
To this time.
No one knew.
Our squadron commander called us together and told us we were headed for the
Philippine islands.
He told us that we were the first part of an expeditionary force being sent out
to beef up the defenses of the Philippines.
After this talk.
I don't remember anyone getting very excited about it.
We all went back to killing time and doing things that we were doing before.
Some people read some gambled and some exercised.
There was light boxing going on,
so I decided I would participate.
I boxed is a lightweight at 165 pounds and I mentioned the 165 pounds because
that weight is gonna go away.
Honolulu is a place where I finally learned the port and starboard sides of a
ship on large shifts.
I still get lost and confused.
I had to go out on deck to see which way the boat was traveling.
Cloak Cape myself.
This is funny.
Where do you get first get on a ship?
You have no idea where you are and there's a,
Oh,
there's a system in a ship that you can use to figure out,
and they mark.
Well,
navy ships,
they market very clearly,
but it takes a little time to get used to and apparently he didn't get taught.
We finally left the dock and as we pulled out of pull harbor,
so all the ships with our planes coming in,
we never saw our plane again.
And little did we realize what would happen to Pearl Harbor and just few short
weeks.
So this is pre Pearl Harbor
so they can say set sail.
They're out at sea.
Back to the book.
One morning when I got up and went out on deck,
I noticed islands all around us.
We were finally in the Philippines just as soon as we got off the ship,
we loaded it into army trucks and were taken to Fort Mckinley.
I should point out here that during the peace time,
I like this part.
I should point out here that during peace time in the Philippines,
prior to our arrival,
the military was on duty only in the morning from eight o'clock to 11 o'clock it
was thought that a white person could not survive and tropical sun after 11
o'clock what a deal they had,
and to top it off,
time spent in the tropics,
Hawaii included,
counted as time and a half toward retirement.
Another reason we were so Honda's when we first arrived in the tropics was the
fact that we still had our winter uniforms,
so I thought that was,
that was pretty funny to think about that.
That's not that.
Well,
this is the 1940s they're thinking,
look,
you're not going to make it.
They listened up white boy,
you're not going to make it past 11 you need to go back in the shade.
Back to the book.
As long as I was at Fort Mckinley about two weeks,
the only thing I ever did was dig trenches around the fort.
These are not Fox foxholes,
but long zigzag trenches.
We were undoubtedly preparing for war.
Then they'd go out there,
they go out,
they catch a movie and back to the book.
After the movie,
we took a tram or trolley back to the gate at Fort Mckinley before going to our
tent,
we decided to stop with the mess tent for something to drink before retiring,
and that is when we heard that Pearl Harbor was being bombed by the Japanese.
This message came from a radio that was playing in a mess tent and I suspect we
were one of the first to hear the news.
I was not terribly surprised or concerned because we'd been preparing for war
and now it was here.
I was not frightened by the news and remember going to bed and immediately
falling asleep because the hour was very late.
I know I would have been frightened if I had known what terrible destruction the
Japanese had inflicted on our forces at Pearl Harbor.
We never knew about our terrible losses until the war was over.
I am sure our top brass knew,
but we were never told,
which I am sure was best.
I may not have been scared the night when I heard that the war started,
but I would be lying if I said I was not scared.
When the second night rolled around the day started with an early frantic call
before breakfast for all to us immediately assembled in front of the first
sergeant's tent.
I had a pretty good idea of what it was all about,
but most of the outfit had not yet heard anyway.
We were told we were now at war with Japan and would be issued arms and
ammunition,
so just like that everything changes.
I was issued a 30 caliber Springfield rifle and a 45 caliber colt automatic
pistol since we were air core personnel.
We had never received instructions on firing a rifle and a lot of these men had
never had a rifle in their hands before.
A lot.
We're like me.
However,
they were farm boys who were brought up with guns and knew how to use them.
So good in these guys.
It's a peace time and even though they might've been preparing for war,
it's a peace time situation.
And you know how I talk about when you're training in Jujitsu,
you can't train hard enough to be prepared for a car.
You can't train the same way a competition fields.
You just,
you just can't.
It's the same way here when there's no war going on.
I don't care how much you're trying to simulate it.
If there's no war going on,
you can't simulate it well enough.
And that's kind of the situation that they were in.
Guys hadn't even,
some of the guys that never even shot a rifle before,
this doesn't take long to escalate at all.
Back to the book that night,
we all retired to our tents early because a total blackout was in effect.
It really made no difference to us because we had no lights in the tents.
Anyways,
all of a sudden,
around midnight or so,
there was a loud whistling and everyone outside,
uh,
loud whistling on the outside by our first sergeant.
The whistling followed by shouts of everyone up.
Everyone up,
air raid.
We could hear air raid sirens in the background,
so we were sure it was the real thing.
A lot of guys were up and dressed and out in minutes,
but a lot of guys were slow and lagging around.
They figured it was a dry run,
so why hurry once out of the tents,
we were told to go to the edge of the jungle nearby and get away from our tents
because they were undoubtably become a great target for the enemy.
Everyone did as he was told,
but before long there was grumbling and people wanted to go back to bed.
Eventually we were given the order to return to our tents.
Needless to say,
we were ready once back in the dark tents,
we got out of our clothes and before long everyone was sound asleep again.
I'm not sure how long we were asleep,
but sometime later that night we were awakened by horrendous sounds,
the likes of which we had never heard before.
Great explosions were going on all around us and the ground was shaking as if an
earthquake was taking place.
Brilliant flashes of light could be seen through the thick canvas of our tents.
By now,
our first sergeant was out again,
yelling for all the head for the jungle.
Again.
This time there were no stragglers of lot of the guys just took off in their
underwear.
Some pants,
no shirt,
some shirt,
but no pants.
I managed to get closed on and untied shoes before leaving our tent,
but once outside I was stunned for a while by what I heard and saw,
the sky was filled with bursting antiaircraft fire and tracer bullets could be
seen headed up in all directions.
The sound of straining aircraft could also be heard,
intermingled with the rumbling sound of exploding bombs.
It looked like the world was coming to an end.
So that's two days to go from,
hey,
we're going to a movie and we're,
we're hanging out in the Philippines drinking some beers to this.
That's,
that's,
that's completely insane to think about.
War had now come to us with a bang and it was real.
Again,
fast forwarding when we received word to pull out of Lipa,
which is where they were.
The reason given was that the Japanese had landed a few miles from us and if we
did knock it out of there in a hurry,
we might be overrun.
So think about that.
You know,
here you are,
you're American,
you've got the strongest military,
you come from this giant country and all of a sudden the Japanese who you
weren't even at war with five days ago,
four days ago,
now they're landing on beach and you're under the threat of being overrun.
I look back now and think that the real story was that the Japs landed in force
and they are commanders wanted all of us evacuated to the Bataan peninsula as
quickly as possible.
So they move,
they march,
they end up in Bhutan,
they no longer have tents and they're living basically outside in little
shelters that they're building and they are starting to get bombed all the time.
Here we go back to the book,
bombs frightened the devil out of me.
I figured there was no way I could survive.
So many close calls day after day.
There was many.
There was many a day when bombs fell within 20 or 30 feet of me and eventually
some much closer.
If it had not been forced,
strategically located foxholes.
I know I would not be here today.
So these guys are getting just crushed because I didn't mention this part,
but uh,
you remember when he said when he,
when they left polar harbor,
they saw the ships with their planes on them.
The planes never showed up.
They got bombed in Pearl Harbor.
So they had like just a few planes that had already been there in the
Philippines.
They didn't have an actual war load out of planes.
So the Japanese had total air superiority and that's why they were able to just
bomb them with,
with complete unrestricted violence
back to the book during a bombing raid,
I would normally peep over the edge of my foxhole to see where the planes were.
At first,
all you knew was that they were headed in your direction and you had better stay
put.
As they got closer and closer,
you could tell better if they were going to pass to the side of you or if they
were coming directly over.
You.
Remember that?
You remember the book we read where I would,
it builds up with the heavies coming.
They the big slow war.
It's Ernie Pyle and he's talking about how the big slow w roar is coming and he
looks up and he sees it's the heavies and how the guys were just so happy that
the bombers were coming.
The big allied American bombers were coming to give them support.
Well,
this is the opposite.
This is what it's like to be on the ground and the heavies are coming.
The Japanese bombers are coming here.
We go back to the book.
If they were directly overhead,
you began to sweat because that mean meant you were about to take a pounding.
As you watched the planes,
you could all of a sudden see many small flashes of silver appear just below the
planes.
This meant that their bombs had been dropped and they were on their way down.
The silver flashes were only visible for a few seconds,
then disappeared.
If you were still looking up,
the next thing you saw and now heard were these large black objects coming at
you with a terrible hissing sound.
Okay?
In a fraction of a second,
they were exploding with a terrific bang as they hit the ground.
They did not go off simultaneously,
but one at a time until they had all exploded.
If the bombs were just in front of you,
you could hear them getting closer and closer and that was the scary part.
It wasn't until you could hear the explosives go past you that you knew you were
safe and could now relax.
That's when you thanked God for foxholes.
So we've talked about similar before with people being in the trenches in world
war one,
I think it was Bobby Hoffman or Bob Hoffman that was talking about in his book.
I remember the last war where when they would get mortared or hit with
artillery,
that's how artillery works.
You fire around,
then you move a little to the left,
then you fire round.
Then you move a little to the left.
Then you fire round and then you move a little to the left and so you knew you
could feel it's getting closer and closer and closer and closer and until it
goes by you,
you're waiting to get blown up.
You're waiting to die.
And that's exactly what he's talking about here.
Back to the book,
besides bombs and enemy strafing,
there was another danger coming from the air.
It was the hot whistling metal fragments raining down on us from our own
antiaircraft guns at Corregidor.
So Craig doors not co located with them and Coreg is firing antiaircraft and
some of the fragments from all that fire is raining down on these guys.
It wasn't long before our food supply was practically gone and we had to
scrounge around to find something to eat.
We eventually eight all of our horses that belonged to the cavalry and the
murals that were used to pull their cannons,
so they ran out of food very quickly.
Although we were air corps,
we were ultimately designated as infantry and carried on and fought as such.
When the front lines we're active,
we could always hear the roar of Canon's being fired in the noise of the
resulting explosions.
Many a night I fell asleep listening to this noise and especially during the
last few weeks and days of our struggle with this noise getting closer and
closer as the front lines fell back.
I never in my wildest dreams felt that we would be defeated.
We were tired,
hungry,
and in many cases sick,
but we were still ready to fight.
So let me just break that down a little bit.
There's infantry soldiers up that are closer to the enemy that are fighting and
they can hear that fighting taking place and they're back at by,
you know,
in their air field area trying to,
well,
they're holding security,
but they're basically around an airfield and the the infantry soldiers in the
army or are further away to the front and they can here day after day.
That front line is getting closer and closer and closer to where they are
because the Japanese are pushing them back and back and back and it ends up like
this.
This is scary.
Ooh,
back to the book.
One day stray soldiers started appearing at our air strip and the surprise me,
because I had never seen this before,
and talking to them,
they said they had left the front line looking for food.
They were being constantly bombarded by Japanese guns and no food was getting to
them.
It was either go out and look for food or starve to death.
So now eventually the guys that are,
we're out fighting the Japanese on front line.
Now there's stragglers starting to come back to the airfield because they're
starving.
Wow.
One day we got word to gas up the last [inaudible] that we had,
three as I recall,
and get them ready for takeoff.
We pulled them out of their hiding place in the jungle and down to the field
where the pilots,
we're waiting.
Normally the pilots wanted to jump in and take off immediately before the Japs
saw them,
but this time it was different.
They said they were leaving baton and going to a field on one of the islands to
the south,
which was still in friendly hands before the pilot got in his plane.
He asked me and a friend of mine if we wanted to send a message home,
we said yes because it was the first opportunity that we had had do so since
leaving the states.
He had a pencil and I wrote a short note letting everyone know at home that I
was,
well
yeah,
when the last of our planes left,
that was the beginning of the end.
It may have been the same day or the day after.
We were hurriedly taken back into camp and told to pack up.
We were told only to bring the bare essentials,
the clothes and shoes that we had on toothbrushes,
et cetera.
Nothing else.
So you know you're in a bad way when the plans are taken off in the guys saying,
Hey,
you want me to pass a message home cause we're not coming back.
And then to get told to,
hey take just the clothes on your back.
Basically we're leaving.
By the time we fault plot finally pulled out,
it was getting dark.
The people that we got back from the field said that they could hear jap tanks
coming up the road and where and they were near for the last several days toward
ward gotten much closer to us.
Gunfire was almost constant at night.
You could see the flash of our canons and here the exploding shells of the
enemy.
It wasn't long before we could hear the drone of Jap bombers coming from a
distance.
We looked up and sure enough they were headed our way.
All of a sudden we could hear this swishing of falling bombs.
They started exploding as they hit the ground and each explosion kept getting
closer and closer working in our direction.
I knew that we were in big trouble when I heard explosions getting louder and
louder.
Then almost immediately we were practically obliterated by an exploding bomb
that missed us by a few feet.
Yeah.
When the bomb went off,
it's sent dirt and large rocks flying in the air in all directions and we were
almost covered by falling debris.
This bomb was actually closer to me than the other bomb that killed the engineer
on our airstrip and peppered my arm with shrapnel.
You could reach out from our foxhole and practically touch the edge of the large
crater that it made,
but none of us were seriously hurt.
Okay,
that's,
that's crazy.
So you've got giant bombs blowing up and you can catch the crater that it leaves
and you're surviving.
That's why you dig foxholes,
by the way.
That's why you dig foxholes cause they provide incredible amount of protection.
That is when we decided we'd better go back and find our outfit.
When we did find our outfit,
we were flabbergasted by the news.
We were surrendering.
I could not believe it.
Okay?
All these men still with arms and now under the protection of Corregidor,
his big guns we were giving up.
But it was true.
We were told to destroy all of our weapons and ammunition immediately in any way
that we could.
Most people were disassembling their rifles and pistols and throwing them into
the bay.
So I did the same.
It was the quickest way to get rid of them.
I did not mind getting rid of my rifle,
but I hated to throw away my pistol.
Yeah.
We were told by our leaders to stay put until the Japs came in.
Yeah,
and when they did,
we would be taken to prisoner of war camps where we would sit out the rest of
the war.
I did not like this idea at all,
but you could tell a lot of the guys who felt relieved they were dirty,
tired,
hungry,
and it had enough of war.
They felt now that they had survived and would soon be fed,
sheltered and given sub long read,
long needed rest.
Little did we know that we were headed for hell.
Okay.
And he goes into some the do you got to get this book and read the whole book
because he goes into all the details of how this collapsed kind of finalized
back to the book.
By the time we got back to the group,
Japanese troops had arrived from the other direction.
They were already lining people up to count us.
Pretty soon a Jap soldier came up to me muttering something and at the same time
flapping his hand up and down.
I looked at him with a puzzled look because I didn't have the slightest idea
what he wanted.
Yeah.
The jap camp is puzzling jet gestures and I could tell that he was getting more
furious.
By the minute
I turned around,
looked at some of the guys and shrugged my shoulders indicating that I did not
know what the jap wanted.
Okay.
Someone said he wants you to sit down,
so I sit.
So I sat down immediately and received a cross,
a crack across my head with a rifle butt.
Okay.
I knew then that that was not what he wanted,
so I immediately got back up.
Okay.
That's when he gave me a shove and the guy next to me,
a shove and so on.
He wanted us to start walking.
That was the beginning of our march out of Bhutan and I believe that I was the
first one to start it.
Okay.
This is where my story is going to be difficult to tell for two reasons.
The first being that we were told on our return to the u s that we were not to
speak to anyone about our experience as prisoners of war,
not the press,
our family or friends.
The reason for this was that somewhere down the line we might be in a war again
and undoubtedly more prisoners would be taken if we revealed how we survived
this information would get into the hands of our enemy,
which would then make it doubly tough on our prisoners.
This made good sense and I did abide by it over the years.
However,
our story has been told so many times now I feel free to tell mine.
The second reason is
okay
that I was and still am reluctant to tell about my experience as a pow is the
fact that I thought it would be impossible to describe what we went through.
Impossible to tell,
an impossible does to describe in written word.
I've since read many good books on the subject and seeing film documentaries
made,
but you had to be there to experience it,
to know what it was like.
Okay.
I know that my meager attempt will also fail,
but I will write about it anyways,
so now we're,
we're clearly,
now we're starting this horrific situation.
This is the,
this is the Bataan death march.
Okay.
As we marched along the road,
we soon,
soon found ourselves without hats and something far more critical water.
The Japanese were quick to take our canteens and empty them on the road and our
steel helmets off with the rifle butts.
Okay.
We were marching through frontline troops that had just overpowered us.
They were still inflicting punishment on us in any way that they could.
We endured constant beatings,
beatings,
beatings.
Every time we ran into a new group down the road.
Okay.
They hit us with rifles,
sabers sticks,
and anything else they could get their hands on.
Yeah.
We were half starved and many so weak.
They could barely walk,
but they showed us no mercy.
The day was torture.
Yeah.
To begin with.
We did not know where we were going and we kept thinking,
surely it couldn't be much further,
but it was
much,
much further.
The Sun on our bare heads was bad,
but the worst was passing up water after water but not allowed any.
Yeah.
After marching well into the dark that day,
we finally stopped completely beat and exhausted.
We felt we would surely now be given food and water,
but that was not to be,
yeah.
They put us in a fenced off yard and told us through an interpreter that if any
of us was found with a knife,
razor blade or anything that could be used as a weapon,
he would be immediately shot.
I thought to myself,
they did not say compass,
but I knew that I would be in big trouble if they found it.
So he had taken a compass and he's keeping that on him in case he ever gets the
chance to escape.
This place was extremely dark,
but there was enough light to see the Japanese soldiers with machine guns
surrounding us.
Okay.
We were packed like sardines with barely enough room to stretch out and no
latrine facilities.
If you had to relieve yourself,
you did it where you were.
I had now gone 48 hours without food and what liquid I had before starting the
march was long gone by way of sweat.
Okay.
There was a lot of talking and moaning going on,
but it stopped immediately when we were told we would be shot if they heard any
noises out of us.
Again,
needless to say,
things quieted down and that is the last thing I remember that day.
Okay.
The next day we were started on the road again before dawn without food or
water,
same treatment by the troops heading into Bhutan,
beatings and more beatings.
We,
we're now plotting along like zombies.
All we could think about was water.
Okay.
And he talks about the fact that they're,
they're passing these little wells,
these little pump and they can see that there's water they could clearly have
and the Japanese are not allowing them to drink this water.
And that was torture is additional torture to what they were going through.
Back to the book,
the countryside that we were now crossing was a total wreck.
The forest was literally destroyed.
It looked like a forest fire had gone through it.
And all that was left with the skeleton of what was formerly giant trees.
No remnants remained of what were once villages.
The roadside was littered with burned out trucks and cars and an occasional tank
could be seen.
They look like total destruction that it was
okay.
The worst part,
however,
was the dead bodies scattered all over.
You could tell that they had been there for some time because they were all now
black and bloated.
The stench was horrible and the site was made more terrible by the swarm of
flies around each body
again all day we staggered along that hot dusty road and though we passed
running artisans wells from time to time we were not allowed to drink.
We had long ago stopped thinking about food.
Now it was water,
water.
You kept thinking,
where are they taking us?
When will it end?
You are thinking,
surely they know we are exhausted to the point of death and they would soon
relent
but they did not and we had to muster every bit of strength that we could carry
on.
Many of the sick and wounded had fallen out before now and the world knows how
they were executed as they fell.
I saw some of this,
but not nearly as much as the people bringing up the rear.
I was fortunate in being near the front of the line and have the strength and
fortitude to stay on my feet
all day.
We look forward to the end of the heat and misery thinking that at night fall we
would stop like we did the night before,
but this was not to be darkness came and we kept going
long before now we had dumped any excess baggage that we were carrying.
A lot of people started the march with blankets,
mosquito nets,
et Cetera,
but by the end of the first day,
this had all been discarded.
It was hard enough carrying your own weight,
much less anything additional for the most part.
Now we were plotting along with strangers.
We,
when we found out we were surrendering,
the squadron broke up and we were lucky if we ran into a buddy.
Occasionally being together as a unit under such a trying situation would
probably have helped.
But that did not happen.
Okay.
So this is just a,
is a nightmare getting worse by the moment.
And I didn't do a good job of explaining that going into this.
It wasn't like they were well fed and well nourished going into this situation.
They had already been under attack and they'd not had food.
They'd run out of food very quickly.
So these guys were already hungry and dehydrated when they started this thing
and now it's just getting
okay.
It's just getting worse.
I do think that the following took place shortly before dark.
On the third day I was desperate for water,
even though I had had some the night before by now,
many of the men were rushing every well that we came to,
even though they were being shot at as they did.
So there were one or two guards close enough to do the show shooting.
So if 10 or 12 men when at once,
the chances were six or eight would get back without being hit.
I decided I would go for it but would wait until late evening.
The opportunity finally arrived.
I made a dash for it with about 10 or 12 others.
Shots were fired,
but I got a gulp of water without being hit
and this continues on and on
word continue.
Word quickly spread that we were finally going to be fed and given water.
How that rumor got started,
I don't know,
but it did not happen.
After a period of about 30 or 40 minutes,
they started marching us out on the road again.
The gate that we went in was the opening between one of the houses and the high
vine covered fence.
As we approach this opening on our way out,
I noticed an army canteen sitting on a small ledge on the side of the house.
My first reaction was at the canteen was a track you would grab it and the jap
guards would shoot you for stealing.
I thought to myself,
trap or no trap,
I am going to grab it.
Which I did is I went by,
it was an easy arm's reach away and somewhat concealed by more ivy growing on
the side of the house.
Another miracle,
it was filled with water,
but I dared not drink it.
Then I had to wait until dark to make sure that a Jap guard did not see me.
It is unexpected happenings like this that helped us to survive.
This is about the time that I started pulling out of it.
By that I mean I no longer expected to stop just up the road to be fed and given
water,
but now knew that the Japanese intended to march us until we all finally
perished.
To this day,
I still believe this to be true,
but I was not going to give them that satisfaction.
So that's a,
that's a hell of a mental transition to make from,
hey,
when are they gonna stop?
When are they going to give us some food?
When are they getting to us?
Give us some water to,
no,
they're not going to and they're going to march us until we die.
And you know what,
I'm not giving in.
Fast forwarding a bit here.
The next day we reached the town of San Fernando where we finally stopped at
least for the rest of that day and for that night here we were finally fad about
a couple of a cup of boiled rice and allowed to have water.
Yeah.
At this point,
many would have said that the rest was more important or appreciated than the
food because many were suffering from incredibly blistered and bloody feet.
My feet were badly blistered,
but not as bad as some who had put on new shoes when they were told to pack up
and get ready to break camp.
I had no new shoes,
otherwise I would have done the same.
There's no way for a person to walk as far as we did without getting blistered
feet.
We spent the night at San Fernando.
Then the next day took off again,
no breakfast of course,
but now at least I had a canteen full of water.
By this time,
we were in an area where the Filipinos had returned to their barrios and Nipa
huts bordering the road,
damage to property and terrain was not as bad as it was further to the south
where more fighting had taken place.
So now they're marching through sort of the regular Philippine villages that
weren't as decimated as the areas where the heavy fighting had taken place.
There were Filipino men,
women and children watching us as we weirdly walked along.
And by the way,
I,
another thing I didn't explain very well,
the Philip,
the Filipino military men were also being marched it simultaneously,
but they had them segregated.
So this is from the American viewpoint.
They could see that the Filipinos were getting treated equally brutal and if not
worse,
and they took massive casualties.
They took tens of thousands of deaths on this,
on this March,
um,
but these,
but now they're walking through where these regular Filipino civilians are
watching this death march take place.
Back to the book in several places,
the women tried to hand food to us,
but the Japanese guards would not allow it.
They had bananas,
mangoes,
and Coconuts,
and it all looks so good.
I never saw it happen,
but supposedly several Filipinos lost their lives to Japanese bullets when they
tried passing food to the Americans.
Yeah.
This was the beginning of the end of the march out of Bhutan,
but we did not know until sometime that afternoon when we arrived at Camp
O'donnell,
so that kind of like you said,
this
is the beginning of the end of the march and here they ended up at camp.
Well,
Donald Campbell.
Donald was a training camp for the Philippine army and was built just prior to
the war.
It consisted of a series of barracks built in typical Philippine style.
The fast roofs had bamboo frame sides and floors and openings for windows,
but no screens or shutters.
Each barracks was about 50 feet long and could be called a double double decker
because the attic was forward as well.
The attic space may have been for storing personal Geren instead of an area for
sleeping.
I say this because the highest point between the floor and the ceiling or the
roof was about five feet.
It would be cramped even for a short Filipino.
I should know because that is where I slept.
Once we pass through gate,
we were made to sit down in an open field with the law was laid down by the
Japanese commander.
I did not pay much attention to what he said except to hear him say that if you
did this,
you would be shot and if you did that you'd be shot.
I wondered what we could do without being shot.
After he was through,
an American officer walked up and introduced himself as general king.
He said that he was the general in charge of the troops on Bataan and he was
solely responsible for our surrender.
He told us not to feel bad or discouraged or guilty because we had nothing to do
with it.
It was his decision and if any blame was to eventually come,
it was his to face.
Yeah,
that's an ownership right there.
I had never heard of the general before,
but he struck me as a brave and sincere officer.
Well,
there you go.
That's what happens when you take ownership people,
the people in your chain of command look and think you're a brave and Sisiro
officer magic.
If he stood up and said,
well,
we didn't get the support that we needed,
and now we're in this position.
It's like,
no.
I later learned that he surrendered the troops on baton without orders from
general Wainwright and MacArthur when he realized that to continue fighting was
useless considering the condition of the men under his command.
Yeah.
He thought for sure that he would be court martialed when the war was over
because his last orders from MacArthur were to attack the enemy an order which
he chose to ignore.
Okay.
He knew that it meant sending hundreds more to their deaths,
something that he would not do.
Needless to say,
he was not court marshal at the end of the war because everyone by then realized
that he did the right thing.
We were finally taken to a barracks and I decided the best place was up in the
loft.
I figured it'd be the quietest and least disturbed.
I took my only possession from around my neck,
my musette bag,
place it on the floor and got some long deserved rest.
The day was about over,
mosquitoes swarmed around my head before I fell asleep.
But I did not have the
energy to brush them off.
Sometimes I think when I read these books about how pathetic.
Hm.
Hm
I am.
And you know how much,
like there's a mosquito in your room and it drives you crazy and you have to
wake up and go kill it because you just can't deal with one mosquito that might
bite you.
Yeah.
And here you are.
Maybe if you're,
you will,
have you ever been in a subtropical place?
It hasn't.
Mosquitoes.
Yeah.
So it can be crazy.
Yes sir.
It can be crazy.
Do you have to sleep with a mosquito net there in your house?
No,
not in the house,
but there,
there are some places where,
yeah,
they all have mosquito net.
And it depends on where you live too.
If you live more up in like a mountain jungley please.
Oh yeah.
Must give them that time sometimes.
Yeah.
So I've been in places where you got to sleep in a mosquito net and,
and
even imagining you think you're some all,
whoa,
this would be a nightmare if I didn't have a mosquito net and these guys are,
they don't have anything close to mosquito.
You have sheets,
have nothing there.
There's nothing to cover themselves from being bit.
So you think about these little tiny things that are like a major trauma when
you're in your normal life.
Yeah.
It's a major trauma.
Like I can't believe there's mosquitoes out right now.
You know what's fun is you still,
you mentioning the mosquitoes still kind of bothering me right now.
Like the thought of mosquitoes being in the room now.
Yeah.
It's kind of fun.
Like we're sitting here letting it bothering you and then you imagine the
situation these guys are in and he's,
he's like,
there's no who cares about mosquitoes.
Yeah.
He's not even brushing them off.
He's too tired to brush him off,
man.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
We are now being
fed a meager amount of rice,
but water situation was still critical.
There was one very slow running faucet out in the yard with a flow capacity of
about a court every 15 minutes or so.
The foster was wide open and that is still all it would deliver.
So even now if and when we got water it had to be stringently conserved.
There was a line at the Faucet always 24 hours a day,
barely enough water to drink and definitely not enough to wash with.
It had now been a week since we broke camp on Bhutan and we had not been able to
wash since.
Okay.
From here on,
I won't be able to recount what happened on a day to day basis,
but I will try to tell what was going on under and under what conditions.
As I mentioned earlier,
we were now getting a small amount of rice each day and for a change in menu
started getting vegetables.
Okay.
Not the part you would normally eat,
but the part that was normally discarded.
Okay.
We were first given boiled carrot tops.
I presume the Japanese were eating the carrots and they generally generously
gave us the tops.
Okay.
They might as well have kept because they were inevitable.
Yeah.
They would not stay down.
They were so horrible and strong.
We would upchuck after a few swallows.
Bye.
Now there were many sick people around with dysentery,
malaria and diptheria.
Every conceivable disease was surfacing because of the physical condition of the
men and the unhealthy conditions under which they were living.
Okay.
The sick were in such bad shape that they no longer stayed in the barracks but
remained outside some under the building stay out of the sun and some lying
outside on the ground near the slit trenches.
Their clothes were all covered with excrement and some had discarded their
clothes preferring to be naked.
Yeah.
These men had dysentery and to die of dysentery was the most horrible way to go.
Okay.
They had to stay outside or near the latrines because with dysentery you pass
blood and mucus every 20 minutes or so.
Yeah.
There is no way to keep from it.
I know these men would have preferred dying fighting instead of in a horrible
way that they were now going
this tree almost invariably men
def.
I think I mentioned that my best friend had drunk,
polluted water and he'd come down with dysentery.
Well,
I now had the initial symptoms even though I did not drink.
I was lucky if you want to call catching dysentery.
Lucky in that my symptoms were occurred a week or so after we reached O'Donnell.
I was lucky because I found out that the leaves from the trees found on the
prison grounds were a cure for dysentery.
I was also lucky because there were still leaves to be found and I was able to
get a good pocket full of them,
which I immediately consumed in a few days.
My symptoms disappeared and also in a few days the trees were stripped bare.
Okay.
Apparently word had gotten out around that.
The leaves were a medicine but there were not enough to go around.
Dysentery spreads so rapidly because the v open latrines and the millions of
flies around them.
They were the same big green flies that we saw in the dead bodies as we walked
out of Bhutan.
Yeah.
There were so many that the branches of small trees around were bent to the
ground.
Sick men were also covered,
especially those near latrine because the latrine itself held the greatest
number.
It was no wonder under these conditions that so many of the prisoners died
besides the flies.
The stench was something else that was always with us.
It was everywhere inside,
outside,
on you and on everyone else.
There was no way to get away from it.
It came with a dysentery and by now the dicentric was also causing the death of
many,
many prisoners.
They were dying by the hundreds.
We heard that as many as 400 were dying each day,
and I remember I looked around to try and determine how many of us were still
alive.
I estimated that the rate we were dying,
we would all be gone within a month or so.
It reached a point where there were so many sick that I decided it was decided
to put them in a separate section.
It was called a hospital officially,
but the prisoners called it the zero ward.
When you went there,
that was the beginning of the end.
Most died within days.
Okay.
The dead were buried in mass graves of about 15 to 20 bodies in each.
Each grade was about five or six feet wide,
eight or 10 feet long,
and about six or seven feet deep.
About as soon as a grave was finished,
there were bodies to fill it
every morning and detail was sent to the hospital to collect the dead and then
take them out to the graves for Vr,
for burial.
I was on this detail several times and it was gruesome.
The dead that we picked up were all naked and were nothing but skin and bones.
Okay.
Several of the dead were from my squadron and one I could only recognize from
his teeth.
Each body was carried by four men,
although now they weighed practically nothing.
Yeah.
The dead were carried on wicker racks,
which at some time were probably used as a door or as a window shutter.
When we reached the graves,
we just dumped them in the open holes.
Yeah.
You could hear the bones crack as bodies were dumped on bodies.
This seemed like a terrible way to treat our dead buddies,
but since they had all died of dysentery,
it was wise to handle the bodies as little as possible.
Yeah,
when the hole is full.
Okay.
It was then covered with dirt,
but no prayer or religious service was given
across the road from us to Filipinos were doing the same as we burying their
dead by the hundreds.
Okay.
Diptheria was a big killer as was cerebral malaria and Barry Barry.
In the early part of our confinement,
there were two kinds of beriberi,
wet and dry.
With the wet,
a person's hands and feet swelled enormously and if the swelling progressed up
the legs and into the abdomen,
death resulted with
the dry form.
There was no swelling,
but it brought excruciating pain to the feet and hands with no lead up.
As far as I know,
this type is not fatal.
I came down with the wet type.
Another killer was hepatitis or yellow jaundice.
I caught it at prison camp
next to dysentery.
Hepatitis was probably the number two killer in the prison camps.
It caused you to lose your appetite,
which is one thing you could not afford to do because the food that you were
getting was barely enough to keep you alive as it was.
It's,
it's,
when you think of,
uh,
just again putting this in perspective,
you know,
when we get sick,
we,
you know,
we take a day off from work and you stay in your bed or whatever,
and the,
these guys,
there's no,
there's no medical treatment whatsoever.
There's nothing.
Okay.
Up to now,
no one had escaped again.
I'm fast forwarding up to now.
No one had escaped.
But one night it happened.
It should not be called escape because these prisoners were caught trying to get
back in the prison camp.
There were three of them and they had been out looking for food or medicine.
I remember they were putting a cage near the gate where the prisoners going and
coming to and from work details could see them.
The cages were in the hot sun and they were not given food or water.
You could tell they were suffering miserably.
But they're suffering only lasted a day or two as I recall,
because late one evening we were called out to witness their execution.
They were made to dig their own graves and fell into them when shot
after these men were shot,
the Japanese came up with an idea that they thought would stop prisoners from
trying to escape.
They put us in what was called blood brother groups and if one of the group
escaped or tried to escape,
the rest would be shot.
Regardless of their complicity.
Later escapes did cause the death of innocent people.
Many of the men felt abandoned and decided that such an existence as ours was
not worth the price of survival.
So they just gave up
dying.
Was it much easier than the fight to stay alive and many chose this way out?
No.
He gets assigned eventually to a bridge detail to build a bridge and this is
kind of wipe,
you know the bridge on the river Kwai type scenario.
You got to go work and help build this bridge back to the book that works was a
short distance from our school.
What's where they were being held and turned out to be the rebuilding of an
enormous bridge that had been destroyed during the war.
When we were not caring and placing timber,
we were made to carry rocks,
rocks from the river bed up to the bridge level,
a climb of probably 30 or 40 feet,
but it felt like scaling Mt.
Everest
dysentery soon weakened our workforce and before long prisoners were again dying
like flies.
Okay.
I could not help but notice one guy's foot.
It looked like it was rotting away and I'm sure he had gang green.
What impressed me about him was his attitude about his affliction.
He seemed to even jovial as we rode back to camp.
I never saw him again,
but it was a miracle if he survived
according to a book written by one of the guys on this bridge detail,
only seven of us were alive at war's end.
Another man had something terribly wrong with him.
I was never sure what the problem was exactly,
but it involved his stomach and I don't know if it was a war wound or what.
He wore a very wide rubber band around his stomach and I was told it was to keep
his intestines in.
Okay.
The rubber band was caught from a large inner tube that's slipped that he
slipped into.
Yeah.
I never did see a stomach beneath the rubber bandage,
but I did see a Japanese guard make him show it to him and the guards stepped
back.
Horrified.
I doubt if this prisoner survived.
They end up at a different prison camp called Kebana,
Twan Cobana.
Twan prison camp was just like O'Donnell and it hard for me to separate them.
In my mind,
I have trouble separating the two prison camps because one was just as bad as
the other little water and dirty,
filthy living conditions back to rice,
but now more soupy instead of dry.
People were still dying with this and treat and other diseases.
I was still in my dirty clothes,
clothes that had not been off my body since leaving our camp on Bhutan
and now they're getting told that they're going to be transported back to the
book.
When we were told we were going to Japan,
the Japanese made it sound like we were going to heaven.
We'd be leaving this stifling tropical heat and going to a climate that was cool
and comfortable.
They get to Manila and eventually they get on a ship.
The ship that we got on was large and apparently carry Japanese troops from
place to place.
I'm not sure how many prisoners board of this ship,
but the number was very high.
Uh,
later estimation put the number at 2000,
we would end up like sardines except we were packed vertically instead of
horizontally.
Yeah.
It turned out lucky that I was to be on the floor because even though I could
not lie down and stretch out,
I could at least sit and stand people crowded in the sleeping bays also did not
have room to stretch out,
but they also did not have enough head space to stand up
by now.
The ship was getting unbearably hot from the heat of the tropical sun and the
large number of prisoners in such a confined space added to it.
Yeah.
It was quickly turning into agony,
but we had not seen the worst
because many of the prisoners were still coming down with dysentery.
Toilet facilities soon became a problem.
All we had was a bucket on top side and the Japanese guards would only let about
two people out at a time.
It wasn't long before we were crowded at the ladder wanting to use the so called
facility.
Okay.
And it also wasn't long before the place became a stinking cesspool.
People soiled their clothes and everyone and everything around them.
If anything,
it was worse than Campo,
Donald,
because now everyone was confined in a small,
overcrowded space and you just could not get away from it.
Getting drinking water was also just as bad because it was also top side and you
got it.
When you went to the latrine
as expected under such conditions,
people began to die.
At first it was maybe one or two a day and some days none,
but eventually it got up to several a day.
Motion of the dying occurred at night for some reason,
and in the morning they were passed up to the Japanese to be thrown overboard.
Nights were probably more stressful because the whole that we occupied was in
total darkness.
You could not see a thing,
but you could hear the constant moaning of men in agony.
Yeah.
One night,
all bedlam broke loose.
There was loud screaming and thrashing of disturbed bodies,
which caused a considerable uproar
in the dark.
You could tell that many people were involved,
even though they could not be seen.
Next morning we found out what happened.
One of the prisoners had gone mad.
Yeah.
And started attacking everyone around him with his canteen.
When he severely hurt several around him,
it was obvious that he could not be restrained.
He was killed by those around him with his own canteen.
Next morning he was lifted out of a hole with several others and slipped
overboard.
His troubles were over.
Okay.
So
I don't know what is much worse than the situation that we're in right now.
Um,
when you have guys going crazy and the only choice that you're left as a fellow
soldier is to kill your fellow soldier to prevent him from hurting anyone else.
Eventually after about three or four weeks,
we came to a complete stop.
We could hear voices on the outside of the ship as our ship was tied up,
research soon learned that we were in a Taiwan harbor
now that we were back out in the open and breathing again,
fresh air felt like we had risen from the dead.
So they,
they get off the ship
and
they end up there.
I mean,
obviously they're,
they're literally covered in shit.
And you know,
when he talked about people with dysentery,
you're,
you're relieving yourself and you're shitting out blood and mucus.
And that's what they're just covered it.
I don't know if this was their original intention,
but after they saw how dirty and filthy would they,
we were,
they decided to clean us up as well as the ship.
They made us strip completely and then blasted us with water from fire hoses,
the force,
the water hurt and stung.
But it felt good.
We had no soap,
but that was all right.
This was the first water I had had on my body since we left our BIVOUAC in book
on Bhutan.
Yeah.
We were also stomping on our wet clothes to hope to work out some of the dirt
and crud as well as that on our own bodies.
While this was going on,
there was a crowd of Taiwanese onlookers taking all this in there.
We're both men and women.
It was about,
now that I noticed my own body,
I was shocked and horrified by what I saw.
Okay.
It was not the dirty body as such,
but the physical condition of that body.
Okay.
I had dwindled to skin and bones and had not been aware of it.
My legs and arms were completely devoid of muscle and flesh and I looked like a
living skeleton.
I was as skinny as the men who had died of dysentery.
It really shook me to discover this.
Okay.
Yeah,
and if you go on the Internet,
you see pictures of guys that were involved in this and they look absolutely
wretched.
They actually look.
Some of them look exactly how he describes it as and they look like living
skeletons.
That's how much,
how,
how completely malnourished they were.
Back to the book.
When we finally did get back on the ship,
we found our so called quarter still dripping wet and now very cold.
Even after we were all back in,
it did not.
It's still not feel warm by now because of the number of prisoners that had
died.
There was a little more space for everyone.
I remember the one guy who had a bunk position now had enough room to lie down.
He was even kind enough to give me his space from time to time to stretch out
and take a nap.
It was funny because we never did learn each other's names.
I think it was the best way because if the person died,
you would not take it so hard.
Just another stranger gone,
so they'd go out at sea again
and then they pull into another port.
Finally,
after many days,
I felt the ship's slow and come to a halt.
I thought Japan at last and now I might get medical help and medicine for my
sickness and pain.
Before long prisoners were called crawling up the ladder out of a hole until the
place was almost empty with my musette bag around my neck and my canteen in it,
I made an attempt to cross over to the ladder,
but that was not to be,
I could not even raise rise.
Much less walk.
Pretty soon to Japanese soldiers came down into the hole and started lifting the
sick and dying to the other Japanese above.
I was not the only one unable to move.
Okay.
When they came to get me,
they lifted me to my feet and drug me over to the ladder.
They wanted me to crawl up and out,
but that was impossible.
I was too weak and I hurt too much.
When they saw I could not do it,
each Japanese guard grabbed me by the arms,
lifted my arms above my head,
then handed me to waiting guards above the jap guards above grabbing by re my
wrists and lifted me out.
How I survived this ordeal.
I shall never know.
The pain that I felt when being lifted by the arms was excruciating.
Okay.
I had never felt anything like it before,
nor have I felt anything come close since.
So
I mean,
he's just,
he ain't can't even stand up.
He's just completely broken and starving and they have to drag him out of there.
Luckily,
they didn't kill him.
They load them onto a truck.
Back to the book.
The truck ride that followed was no joyful experience either.
Now my bones began to take a beating as I lay on the metal bed of the truck.
I was being bounced around because of a very rough road and I had no flesh on my
bones to CAUTI cushion each bounce again,
pain and misery.
When would it end?
Finally,
we arrived at what appeared to be an army camp and the trucks drove up to one of
the barracks.
Once inside we found the place to be very clean and nice and warm.
There was snow on the ground outside,
which accounted for the heat inside.
There were even straw filled mattresses and blankets for each man.
Okay.
We learned a little later that we were not in Japan,
but in a place called Pusan Korea.
I had never heard of it before.
Okay.
So now they're,
obviously they're in Korea now and you can see the treatment gets a little bit
better.
There's a little bit of influence from the Koreans trying to be a little bit
more humane.
I think
all back to the book as all as in all the places I had previously been,
people were dying at the rate of two or three a day.
Okay.
They were picked up in the morning when the doctor came in and taken out and
cremated.
Okay.
By then,
you could tell when a person was about to die.
They had what we called a death grin.
The skin was stretched so tightly across their flesh list,
faces that their mouth state permanently open as though grinning
a person in that condition was not long for this world.
There was another condition that we called the death rattle.
This also meant death within a few days.
I was shocked beyond belief.
One morning when the person next to me said that during the night I was making
the rattling sound.
After that,
I was afraid to go to sleep because that was usually what a person died.
I remember fighting to stay awake night after night.
The nights seem to last into eternity and I remembered how glad I was to hear
the sound of the crows and the distance.
It meant morning was near and I was still around.
You reach a point where dying becomes easy,
but staying alive is a battle.
Okay.
Many chose not to fight any longer.
I would say that after two or three weeks,
the dying ceased.
There were about 20 or 25 of us left and we were slowly starting to get out of
bed and move around some.
So like I said,
they're starting to get a little bit more fruit,
a little bit better treatment.
Okay.
One thing that I'm not sure of in my mind is when the Japanese finally gave us
new clothes and shoes to wear,
the clothes we were given were all Japanese army issue shoes,
cap shirt,
pants,
socks,
underwear and coat.
These were Japanese summer uniforms and clothes and not willing uniforms that
our guards were now wearing.
We hated having to wear a jap uniform,
but we really had no choice.
So
now they actually end up on a train and they go for a long train lot ride.
And when they finally get off,
um,
the place looked like and felt like the inside of a deep freezer,
everything was covered with snow and frozen solid.
And then they get put into a truck after they get off the train in this frozen
area and they travel out from the train area,
from the train station away from the city and they keep going and they keep
going.
And finally to get to a place that looks like a prison.
Back to the book,
I remember there were several buildings,
possibly a dozen or more,
but I am not sure of the exact number.
The buildings were low to the ground and barely visible because of the thick
blanket of snow that cupboard.
Everything.
We stopped shortly at one of the buildings and unloaded again.
I needed assistance.
I wasn't in the building more than five minutes on one of the men said that my
nose was frozen to our frostbitten and I had better quickly do something about
it.
If I knew my frost,
my nose was frost,
a frozen my feet,
surely we're also both my nose and feet blistered horribly and turned black and
blue like a bad bruise.
The skin eventually peeled off and I was fine except for some badly scarred
feet,
so I didn't go into enough detail.
But while they're transporting in these trucks,
it's freezing.
And so you've got these guys that are in whatever summer uniforms and by the way
there the way nothing,
they have no zero,
they literally have zero body fat on them and they're freezing and these trucks
and he gets frostbite.
Back to the book,
we also found out that we were near the city of moon den Manchuria.
We'd come from the furnace of the tropics into the deep freeze of the Arctic and
if you remember that name might sound a little bit familiar,
moot in Manchuria.
That is one of the locations where the Japanese,
the unit seven 31 did experiments on Caucasian.
They wanted to have Caucasian prisoners to do experiments on to make sure that
the reactions to biological and chemical weapons were the same as they were on
the Asian prisoners' that they had been using on them.
I'm on the Chinese prisoners.
They'd been using these,
these chemical weapons on and these biological weapons on and so that's where he
is now.
Settle in a little bit here.
Before long it was lights out time.
I again became aware of how weak I was.
I tried to call crawl under my blankets.
When I read this,
I was thinking about this.
Let let,
so listen this,
I tried to crawl under my blankets but could not lift them.
Eventually with the help of others,
I managed to make it.
The commerce felt good for a while,
but before long my body began to ache from the weight of the covers and I had a
miserable night.
If I removed the blankets,
I would freeze and if I left them on,
I would hurt.
I decided hurting was better because I was used to that by now.
Yeah,
it was the next day or close to it to the Japanese,
came around and gave,
gave each man a number.
Mine was 1439
about this time we were also weighed,
we replaced on a foot scale.
I figured I weighed around 90 pounds after subtracting for food for shoes and
clothing.
So if you remember,
he was boxing at one 65 and as you know,
like a boxer,
it's not like you're,
you don't have a lot of weight on you.
You're not sitting around with a bunch of extra weight.
So now he's under 90 pounds.
And why are they getting weighed?
Well,
he didn't know at the time.
Why are they getting weighed?
They're getting weighed because they're going to be experimented on.
And he doesn't really connect the dots in this book,
but you know,
obviously they're getting weighed because they're there.
They're trying to figure out how much weight they're going to lose and how much
weight they're gonna gain and how of the,
how long it takes him to get sick.
And the and if you remember it,
unit seven 31 one of their goals was to keep the prisoners healthy enough that
they could experiment on them,
so that is one
I guess small benefit to to this situation,
if I could even call it that.
I guess I can't,
but there's one upside to this is that since they're going to be used as
experiments,
and again he doesn't talk about it too much and it's not very clear,
but they start feeding them better.
Back to the book,
going to beans from rice,
I'm sure saved many prisoner's lives as I am almost positive it's saved mine
beans are rich in vitamins and protein.
While rice is a starch or a carbohydrate which we know is not
good.
Contrary to expectations,
coming to a cold climate did not stop the dying.
The first winter was the worst with the killers still being dysentery happened.
Titus and now pneumonia was added to the list and again,
who knows how many of these diseases were actually inflicted on on the prisoners
by the Japanese because they're in a cold climate.
Why are they getting these tropical diseases as well?
Back to the book here,
the sick and dying had a new scourge.
Body Lice.
They were crawling all over by the thousands.
Body hair,
clothes,
you name it.
They were there in the heat of the tropics.
It was flies and here it was body lice.
Body lice probably spread germs as readily as flies.
Everyone had lice,
but those were well enough to keep the number of lice down.
They got in the seams of your clothes.
They went when they were not biting you and that is where you look for them.
Yeah.
As they were discovered,
they were squashed between your fingernails exposing the blood.
They had sucked from your body that Chinese Cooley's did not let them get away
with their blood because they ate them.
When they were discovered,
I Chinese coolie at rest was always searching for lice.
Come to think of it,
we were to,
at least at this time,
during that first winter,
all the dead were placed in a storage building that was necessary because the
ground was still frozen,
solid,
making impossible to dig graves.
Burial could not.
Therefore take place until mid to late spring.
When the time arrived,
a large burial detail was sent out to dig graves.
Even when even then digging was difficult because only the top eight to 10
inches of the ground had was fought with frozen rock.
Hard soil below this was permafrost country.
Okay.
When the graves were finally Doug,
we went for the bodies.
We found them stacked like cordwood again,
this,
this is remnants of unit seven 31 because they were still frozen solid as in the
Philippines.
They were all naked.
They look like skeletons with skin stretched over their bones.
The one difference was many of the bodies were lemon.
Yellow.
Yeah.
They had died from hepatitis or so called yellow jaundice.
Although it was prevalent in the tropics,
it was catching up with us now.
Now eventually he gets well enough and they put them on a work detail in a
factory and
still dealing with troubles.
Back to the book,
when we were in prison campuses in the Philippines,
our strongest want or desire was water.
Food was secondary.
Now that we had sufficient water,
it was food that was constantly on our minds.
I remember how we used to say it.
If we ever got back to the states,
we would carry food with us wherever we went.
If we had a house,
it would be full.
If we had a car,
the trunk would be loaded.
The pockets of our clothes would also be stuffed with candy bars and peanuts.
We could at least dream if nothing else.
And so this is pretty cool there in this factory and what they're doing is
they're preparing their,
this work detail is to prepare a factory for the Japanese and the,
they're putting a cement floor in and they've got these big machines that are
going to be used to build whatever and here we go.
The machines that were in crates were brand new and consisted of metal lathes,
large drill plastic presses,
extremely large shapers and others that I was not familiar with.
Closer investigation,
they found a little wooden box in the corner for each created machine.
Closer investigation revealed that the wooden box contained handles knobs,
dials,
screws,
bolts,
et cetera.
In other words,
precision tools and essential parts that went with the machine right away.
We knew what we had to do with them to get rid of them.
We started by taking the smaller parts and dumping them in the latrine and the
same old saddle trench style,
but eventually got bolder when a whole was completed and ready to be filled with
concrete.
Someone grab a bunch of parts and throw them in the hole where they would be
quickly covered without these important parts,
the machines would be useless.
That's like hardcore.
These guys are still resisting.
It's still fighting.
They want the Japanese to be able to build anything
so they destroy these parts.
I mean that's at risk of obviously that's at risk of death.
You get caught doing that,
you're going to get killed.
They eventually move to a different camp
and this one looks,
it's another one that looks just like a prison
and he talks about some of these other diseases.
When I wrote,
when I wrote earlier of diseases that existed among the prisoners in the
Philippines,
I forgot to mention that we also had much scurvy and something else called Guam
blisters.
They were like a Ross or without a scab,
but they started as small as a small blister,
which would not heal,
but kept getting bigger and bigger.
Since there was no medication to cure them,
they would eat away at the entire layer of skin leaving the flesh below exposed.
As the blister grew and devoured more skin,
no scab formed,
which made for an ugly looking sore
where the good skin was being eaten away.
There was all always a small rim of Pos.
Some of these blisters has got as large as a silver dollar and some of the
prisoners had several.
At one time I was lucky I did not have one,
but I did have a very large ring warm on my stomach.
It was about the size as a saucer and getting larger by the day.
So there's something all of us do,
Jujitsu people can relate to.
You get a ring warm,
that's the size of a dime and it's like a nightmare.
And here you got a ringworm that's the size of a saucer
and it gets worse.
Here we go.
Here came the fleas.
They only showed up in great numbers at night,
but then it was by the hundreds.
They were actually a lot more aggravating than the lice.
Their bite was a lot more painful and they made it almost impossible to sleep at
night.
I reached a point where it reached a point where our underwear looked like it
was made from polka dotted material,
when in fact it was spotted with dry blood.
Even though we were in much better quarters our food and not improved.
So we still had much sickness and some dying still tuberculosis was now killing
people and Barry Barry was still prevalent.
You know,
I think I've been bitten by a flea five times in my whole entire life.
Maybe zero here,
zero for Echo Charles.
And here are these things that are,
they're biting you so much that your underwear looks like it's spotted.
Like it's Polka dotted.
Yeah.
Another person had dry beriberi so badly that he consented to be taken to a
place in Mukhsin where the nerves to his feet were severed.
It apparently relieved his pain,
but it's now his feet now looked floppy to me like you did not have any control
of them anymore.
Well,
yeah,
they cut his nerves.
Bye now.
My main problem was with my teeth.
I had developed bad cavities in two back teeth and they hurt constantly,
so now his teeth are all jacked up,
so now he goes to a,
to a supposedly a dentist.
I sat down in the chair,
one of the Japanese reach for an instrument and I instinctively opened my mouth.
He reached in and immediately I felt this horrible pain.
I fought good and is finally out in another second or two more pain just like
the first and more and more.
What was happening was that the Japanese was not pulling yet.
He was just cutting the gum away from the two so he could reach way down on it
and get a good grip for pulling.
Luckily it finally came out with at an out any problem,
the pulling was less painful than the cutting.
I forgot to mention there was no Novocaine or other painkiller provided when the
teeth were pulled.
Don't like that one.
No,
sorry man.
Cause you know when you go to the dentist,
it's nerve.
You know,
I,
I actually considered whether or not I should put that in there.
Cause I know there's some people that really don't like going to the dentist.
I myself was never,
never really cared and it was not that big of a deal to me to go to the dentist.
But I know that some people have like a legitimate phobia of the dentist and I
apologize.
I'm sure that last little section isn't going to help out.
No,
no.
And I don't know that I'm a phobia.
I think I'm normal dentist.
Um,
regarder I guess their regrets,
but it is nerve racking though.
So you know,
you don't want the dentist,
you know when they,
when they do put novacane right then needle for some reason it doesn't hurt.
I don't know.
Does it hurt?
You don't feel the needle right?
Like with less than like if you,
even if you got like a blood test or something.
Anyway,
so,
so you're all numb,
but when they bust out that drill and doing like all that stuff they do in
there,
it's nerve wracking because you're like,
cool,
I can feel it grinding my teeth out,
whatever they're doing.
And then,
but you don't really feel the actual pain every once in a while,
you know?
So it's just you're constantly at this high stress level and then now this guy,
no,
we can't basically what year at the stress level for,
he's just taking it head on hundred percent
and then he's like,
hey,
when they pulled out my tooth,
it wasn't as bad as the cutting.
No.
Cutting your gums is not going to be a good situation.
Yes.
No Sir.
It's not for a very long time now,
we had had no news about the progress of the war.
The Japanese kept telling us that before long they would be sitting in the White
House in Washington.
None of us believed this propaganda,
but why was it taking the u s so long to beat the Japanese?
We did not,
or at least I did not know about Pearl Harbor and maybe that was a good thing
not knowing had we known.
I know that our morale would have sunk to the bottom of our toes and he's just
talking about the mass destruction that that when that happened
so far I have not mentioned anything or very little about our thoughts of home
and family.
It was a personal thing with every one of everyone and was little if ever
discussed,
but you can be sure that it was on everyone's mind.
If others were like me and I'm sure most war you thought about your parents back
home almost every night and knew how they were suffering,
not knowing where you were or how you were or even if you were alive or dead.
This must have been an agony to them.
The same could be said of brothers and sisters and wives and children.
I always felt that the prisoners who suffered the most mentally,
we're the ones with wives and children back home.
I know it was extra hard on them,
but they were few in number.
Most of the men were young and not married.
So That's interesting.
If you remember when Captain Plumb was on,
I think those guys got to a level where they knew they were going to survive and
even cabin plum said he didn't think he was going to die.
You know,
he said,
Aye,
Aye.
I was going to live like he thought that they were going to live through the
war.
But I think for these guys it must be a different,
and that's why the guys that were in like the Hanoi Hilton,
remember they knew everything about everyone's life in every single story that
you would try and remember every single possible thing that you could about your
whole life and tell it to your roommate.
But I think these guys are in such a state where survival is not a known entity.
And so I think it sounds like,
and he mentioned earlier that not knowing people was actually easier.
So it's sort of a different psychological situation
now he goes on,
I know everyone enjoyed going to sleep at night and if you dreamed it was
usually always the same,
but it left you extremely depressed the next day.
In most dreams you were at last freed from prison camp and back in the states
and feeling euphoric,
free,
free again.
How wonderful.
Yeah,
but the shock of awakening was so heartbreaking when you found out you were
still in prison.
I believe these dreams actually did more harm than good.
Even so they came back time and time again.
There was no getting away from them.
No,
the people not home,
we're not forgotten.
And we knew they had not forgotten us.
So that's,
you have these beautiful dreams that everything's cool and then you wake up and
you're still in prison camp.
Back to the book,
the Japanese put everyone to digging foxholes.
They were not for us,
but for the Japanese somewhere at the factory in some of on the Japanese side of
the camp,
but none were.
None were on our side.
When this work started,
we knew that the Japanese were now expecting expecting possible error rates and
we were excited because the war was getting closer.
It wasn't too much longer.
After we finished digging all of the Fox holes that we were required to cover
them over,
they were covered with heavy timbers and then further covered with a large
amount of dirt.
This told the Japanese that we were taking,
this told us that the Japanese were taking a pounding somewhere,
which in our minds was great at about the same time the Japanese were becoming
rather aggressive and there was a definite change in their attitude and
treatment of us.
We now had to really watch what we were doing and if we did anything illegal,
make sure we were not caught.
Some of the men were caught.
However,
it's suffered the consequences,
so this is great news there.
They're like,
oh,
you got to dig in.
That means Americans are common.
Okay.
One morning,
shortly after we had gone to work,
air raid sirens started going off all over the city and everyone became very
excited,
especially the Japanese.
We were quickly rounded up and made a double time back to camp.
This time we were not searched but sent immediately to our barracks and told to
stay inside.
We could still hear sirens going off in all directions.
We had not been back to our barracks and very long.
When the Japanese came back and said,
everyone outside in the yard,
our yard was probably 150 to 200 feet long and perhaps a hundred feet wide,
more or less.
When everyone was out,
the Japanese made us lie down and then took off probably for their foxholes.
It wasn't long before we could see a large formation of heavy bombers headed our
way.
They were up very high and each left a streak in the sky that extended for many
miles behind it.
It was a beautiful site and we felt proud and excited.
It had to be American planes and the war had reached Manchuria.
We watched them slowly come our way,
but the Japanese also saw them coming and sent up fighter planes to intercept
them,
which was a mistake from the ground.
It looked like a swarm of mosquitoes going after a flock of geese,
and the comparison is good because that is about how effective the jap fighters
were
from the ground.
We could see flashes of fire coming from the bombers and see Japanese planes go
plunging down in smoke.
Just about then you could hear the roar of the guns from the bombers as the
sound reached the ground time after time the Japs moved in,
but the results were the same.
Japs going down in flames with no apparent damage to the bombers.
What a fight.
Okay.
I would like to interrupt writing about this attack at this point to mention
that our prison camp was in the middle of a heavy,
a heavily industrialized area,
which is was against international rules of war.
We should not have been imprisoned.
Where we were,
right next to us was an ammunition factory and a short distance behind us,
a tank factory.
We were very close to an airplane factory and a major rail yard.
There were numerous military targets for Americans to bomb and unfortunately we
were right in the middle of them.
Still lying on my back.
I kept my eyes on the bombers and was impressed by the large number in the
formation about 18 or 20 as I recall.
Pretty Soon I could see the silver flashes of released bombs and then in another
few seconds saw the sky filled with hundreds of bombs hurdling down on us and
making their typical loud swishing sound.
I knew they would not miss and they did not.
Three of the bombs from the plain on the outside of the formation hit our camp
and the destruction was horrible.
One of the bombs landed near the high brick wall that surrounded our compound
and knocked a big chunk out of its top.
The bomb fell right in the yard where we were allying and instantly killed 19 of
us and severely wounded many more.
The third bomb was an incendiary and fell in our barracks and set it on fire.
It was a tragedy hair we were after so very long,
a time excited beyond belief at watching our side win for a change and look what
happened.
We could hardly believe it,
but we were now being killed by our own bombs.
Even though I was within 20 feet or so of the bomb,
I was not hurt.
I looked up,
as I looked up,
I saw men black and from the blast try to rise but fall back terribly wounded or
dead
again.
It's the heavies from the other,
the other side,
the other perspective.
Now at a certain point,
one of those bombs,
one of those bombers did get shot down and the the air crew and pilots from the
aircraft that got shot down got captured and so here we go.
These were men who had survived the blowing up in there be 29 bomber and we're
now being held captive in a house within sight of our camp.
Okay.
They said they did not know of our prison and they get communication with them.
They said they did not know of a prison camp and in actuality it was marked on
there.
Ma maps as a must get target.
This wasn't terribly reassuring,
but they did pass on more cheering information than that.
They said Japan was being defeated all over the Pacific and it,
uh,
it appeared that the war should not last two very much longer by the action in
the sky.
We had already come to assume that they also said that they were flying out of,
from the island of Guam.
Okay.
There was always the positive.
They feel like the war.
Okay.
This is obviously a really positive side.
The jap Japanese are getting beat all over the Pacific.
The bombers are there,
even though it's horrible that they're getting bombed.
They at least feel like the war is heading in the right direction.
But then there's this back to the book,
there was always the possibility.
We felt that when the war was over or about over,
and the Japanese realize that they had lost.
They may decide to execute all of us instead of letting us go free.
So they got that in the back of their mind
little section here.
He gets in some trouble.
One morning when we arrived at the factory and headed for our work in the lumber
yard,
we noticed Japanese soldiers all over the place.
They were running and crawling and obviously playing war,
so the Japanese were running a drill.
We just ignored what was going on and walked right through them to get to our
shack.
When we were in the process of hanging up our coats,
when a jet,
we were in the process of hanging up or quotes when a Japanese officer burst in
on us and he was mad,
mad,
mad.
Okay.
So he gets in trouble.
The the Japanese officer that's all mad lines up,
everyone in the little shack and he has his saber and his left hand and he
started punching each guy in the face and that's what,
that's what he does and he ends up,
they ended up getting in trouble because they got punched.
I guess they got in trouble because they got punched and finally that he's going
to be questioned and he's in this going to get questioned.
This guard house,
which is sort of like where they do solitary confinement in this,
in this guard house,
the prison within the prison.
So the,
so James is about to get
interrogated back to the book.
He asked me if I thought that the Japanese officer at the factory had a right to
hit us the way he did.
I hesitated for a second,
like I was pondering the question then answered,
well,
I am not sure.
Just as soon as these words came out of my mouth,
I knew that I had answered wrong,
but nothing happened and I was questioned a bit further until the same question
came up again.
Did I think that the Japanese officer at the factory had the right to hit us the
way he did for a second?
I was in a quandary.
Should I just say yes sir?
Or should I repeat my first answer?
I decided maybe being consistent.
The way to go,
sorry.
I repeated my original answer and that was a mistake almost instantly.
I was hit on the right side of my jar with a closed fist,
not by the officer,
but by the interpreter.
Okay.
From that point on.
He decided to slap me in the face as hard as he could.
I think he really hurt his fist when he heard me the first time,
which is why he changed to the slap.
All the while you are being beaten.
You were being made to stand at attention with this kind of beating.
You don't give them the satisfaction of knowing you letting them know you are
hurt.
You just don't let yourself fall down and Moan.
All I could think about was you little son of a bitch.
If I could just get you a loan under different circumstances,
I would tear you apart.
After the beating stopped,
I was thrown into the guard house with the rest of the guys.
The inside of my mouth was badly cut and I swallowed blood for several days.
My face was swollen and I had black eyes.
Yeah.
I stayed in the guard house for about three weeks.
Conditions in the guard house were unbelievably cruel and I hope I can explain
exactly what it was like.
It was built similar to our barracks.
Excepted had cells instead of separate sleeping quarters.
There was a central hall with cells on either side.
Each cell was about eight feet wide and probably 12 feet long with a very narrow
slit trench,
fertile latrine in the back corner.
The floor was concrete and that was it.
No bed blanket chair or anything else.
The guard,
the guard house was solitary confinement at its worst.
Yeah.
I found the hardest thing to take was the boredom.
You've heard the song time goes by so slowly.
Well,
it certainly applied then standing in one place,
even if not at attention,
can be a killer.
Yeah.
I used to watch a spot of light that came in through the crack on the board at
window and it almost drove me mad.
Okay.
I tried to ignore it,
but I couldn't.
Okay.
It would be made to get up.
I would be made to get up in the morning at five o'clock and several hours later
when there were sufficient light,
the spot would appear.
It first showed up on one side of my cell and then moved so terribly slowly
across the other side until it finally disappeared after was gone.
I knew I still had several hours to go before I would get rest.
It was agony to watch and it was the same thing day after day after day.
Yeah,
and then eventually we were probably released when we were without the usual
trial and sentencing because the Russians invaded Manchuria
and here we go.
At this point,
I would like to refer you to a diary that I started on August 15th,
1945 and continued until September 2nd,
1940 it tells the story as it was happening,
which is much better than my trying to recall events 50 years later,
the diaries short,
but I think it's worth including here.
So
basically we,
we end up with him getting released and he starts tracking what's happening
because he can,
there were some Americans that were brought into the situation and he starts
keeping a little journal as he said.
And I'm just going to read a little bit,
a little bit from the journal.
Americans working at the Japanese garage brought in news that about the same
time that the war was definitely over.
They said that a nip told them that Japan had surrendered at nine 30 o'clock on
the 15th of August.
These men were willing to bet anything on this dope.
Yes,
optimism reigns supreme and I had never seen excitement such as this before.
Okay.
But such a heart rendering drop came a little while later when word was passed
around that these six new men had been placed under locking key in the guard
house.
Yes.
Morale rating was now zero minus.
Okay,
now we'll go August 17th this morning we found out who these new men are.
They are American volunteers who were flown over from China to take over this
prison camp and to see that the Japanese did not mistreat us.
Also set up communications between here and our American forces.
The story of their undertaking is very thrilling in these men deserve a word of
praise and credit for they're brave deed.
Okay,
and then this happens.
The American assembly call was blown about eight o'clock and we formed outside
where General Parker,
the senior American official,
made a speech before he would cut us in on the real dope.
He told us that we must be calm and maintain a hold on ourselves.
He emphatically stressed that there were to be no demonstrations.
He proceeded to tell us of the armistice between America,
England,
the Netherlands and Japan,
which brought about a roaring cheer from the prisoners,
but he warned us that we were still prisoners and that Japan and Russia,
we're still at war.
Okay.
This little speech brought happiness to everyone even though we knew what he was
going to say before he started.
This was the news that we had been waiting to hear for three and a half years
and it was now official man,
three and a half years,
so I just buzzed through this in an hour and 47 minutes right now,
and this is three and a half years.
You got to get the book and then you got to think about even more than what
school you read about in the book.
We were still under Japanese guard,
but the administrative ministration of the camp was taken over by Americans.
Yeah,
we really,
we really chowed like we should have now that we had the keys to the storeroom.
So boom,
let's go.
There's,
there's,
they start seeing Russian pursue planes over the camp.
Um,
the Sunday,
the 19th held church services to get today in Thanksgiving for our wars,
ending more Russian planes overhead.
Today the men really got a thrill out of seeing friendly plains.
Again,
they're all anxious to see the American air force and it's large bombers that
they have heard so much about Monday,
August 20th,
we were told today that the Russians would be in camp,
saw our first be 24 bomber today at a route four 30.
The prisoners really went wild with joy.
It's circled over the camp three,
two or three times and drop leaflets telling us about the war being over and for
us to remain where we were until help arrived.
These leaflets were late.
They should have been dropped before the parachute is came in.
And that's the,
the rumor mill.
The guys that had come in earlier.
The Russians came in at about seven o'clock and did they cause great excitement.
There was a general in five or six officers.
The general call does together and gave us a speech.
An American prisoner acted as an interpreter.
The general said that from this day on we were free and no longer under the hand
of the Japanese.
The crowd went wild with joy,
cheer after cheer rang through the air.
He told us how in the last 10 days they'd covered 1000 kilometers of mountain
streams and wilderness more cheering from the crowd.
He told us that he was in Berlin when Germany surrendered and met officers of
the U s eighth army.
He said that he would,
he told them that he would soon be leaving to fight Japan and that he would set
us free.
Also had a ceremony of the surrender of the Japanese guards and the turning over
of their sabers and arms to the American guards.
It was quite an interesting and strange spectacle.
What made it appear strange was that it was performed in the light of the moon.
The Russian general presented General Parker with a Japanese revolver.
This ceremony was completed by the Russian general having the American guards
parade the Japanese before the prisoners and off the parade ground.
Man,
the restraint is,
is,
is insane.
I mean,
yeah,
I can't,
I,
it's hard for me.
Um,
I've considered myself to be a pretty,
you know,
emotionally controlled person and I think if I was in that prison for three and
a half years and the war ended and the Japanese that had tortured and beat and
starved,
we might have a little something to talk about.
Am I a little something for those guys?
A little bit more than just marching them around the camp.
But you know what that shows you,
it shows you that that's the,
that's how professional the American soldier is,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
We got this from,
from units seven 31 those books as well.
The people that were being tortured,
they got turned over by the Russians and said,
do what you want with them.
And,
and the,
the determination was we're going to treat them humanely.
No.
Back to the book.
Back to the diary,
September 2nd we have been moving.
We have,
we've been having moving pictures.
He means movies for at least two nights and I've never enjoyed anything so much
before in all of my life.
Being in prison camp for so long almost made me forget what was going on back in
America.
I am just beginning to realize now what I have missed.
If I would've seen a movie two years ago,
I'm afraid I would have tried to escape at any cost.
If I would've realized to what I was really missing this long time in prison
camp would have been much harder to bear,
more sick left by plane.
Today our new colonel told us that we would probably be out of here,
out here for at least another month.
What's a measly month more after having been here for so long.
In fact,
it is good to know that we will be leaving for home and only a months time.
Okay.
Yeah.
When you kind of consider in his mind it's either,
it went from never to one month,
so it's like,
oh,
all right.
You could do that month.
Yeah.
It's also interesting how he,
he got detached from what the world had and he actually found that beneficial in
it.
And I've talked about the robe.
The first interview I did with Tim Ferriss,
I talked about how it kind of detached from
okay,
from what's going on,
you know,
from like pictures of my kids and didn't hang them up cause I want,
I didn't want to be thinking about that because I'm there to do the job and yet
you can see that he's saying he would have gone crazy and tried to escape if
he'd known he was missing
back to the book.
When we finally got to see what the Japanese had on their side of the prison
camp,
we were astonished and mad.
They had a room full of mail and packages from the states that they never
delivered plus a large quantity of Red Cross packages.
We speculated that the Japanese were living off our red cross packages when food
became scarce food that was meant for us.
Bye.
Now
since we were all free to leave prison camp and wander,
everyone was looking for a Japanese saber to take home as a souvenir from the
war.
It would show that at long last in the end we were the winners and they were
vanquished.
Yeah.
Eventually and again get the book
the he's leaving booked in.
I was on the last truck out and as we pulled away I saw the Russians come out of
the front gate with the Japanese and walk on the outside of the brick,
walled toward the back of the camp.
My impression was that they were going to line the Japanese up against the back
brick wall and shoot them.
Check.
I'm supporting the Russians in this one.
I think
back to the book there.
They end up in up in the port in in China where they're going to get their ride
home on a ship.
There was an American transport waiting for us to dock,
but when the ship captain saw all of us armed with rifles and Sabers,
he would not let us on the ship unless we gave up our weapons.
We said,
no way,
captain.
These are ours and we're not going to part with them.
He then said that he would safely store them for us and they would be returned
when we docked.
Our reply was an emphatic no.
By now.
We were looking for a place to sack out because we were not going to board that
ship without our arms.
Well,
after a lengthy delay,
the captain relented and we were finally allowed on the ship with our sabers
clanking at our sides.
They,
he talks about they go,
they'd go through great efforts to get these Japanese sabers
once on the ship.
We were given a cursory medical check deloused and giving clean clothes,
I believe before being taken to our living quarters.
Our dispute with the captain,
the ship wasn't over now and everyone could relax and clean quarters on a very
comfortable bed.
This was the first real mattress that I'd slept on since leaving the SS Coolidge
almost four years ago.
Okay.
It felt great and the food provided was also very good.
Now our minds and bodies,
we're truly at ease.
No mattress for f you,
you know,
when you got to like sleep in the airport or whatever and you complain about it,
that's a carpet that's actually a pretty good deal.
And you've got a sweatshirt that you've wrapped up in and you put a little
something under your head.
Oh,
bathroom too,
by the way.
Yeah,
there's a nice bathroom,
right?
There's not lice digging into your skin or fleas eating at your
four years,
four years on the dirt.
Okay.
Um,
so now they get to,
they sail from there to Okinawa.
Once they're in Okinawa,
they're doing a little bit of port time in Okinawa,
getting some supplies where soon told that a strong typhoon was headed our way
in.
The safest place for us was in the open water instead of the shallow bay.
Before long,
the island of Okinawa disappeared in the distance and night wasn't long in
coming.
So there's a big typhoon coming.
They take,
they get back on board,
this ship,
they head out to sea.
I must've fallen asleep eventually because about four o'clock in the morning I
was awakened when the ship was rocked by a tremendous explosion.
I could not imagine what it was because it was a lot worse by far than an
exploding depth charge.
Before I got completely dressed,
I could hear sailors working their way down toward us shouting everyone topside,
everybody top side and prepare to abandon ship
everybody topside,
hurry,
hurry and he goes through some of the details.
We had hit a
which tore a hole in the side of our ship and flooded the engine room and in
turn knocked out our power.
There was a possibility that this ship might sink,
which is why we were all ordered tops.
I didn't give him life preservers we had all,
we had to be ready to abandon ship if needed.
Even if we abandoned ship,
I doubt many of us would have survived.
It was still dark and on top of that there was no possible way to lower the
lifeboats with the ship lurching back and forth as it was once on deck,
we had to tie ourselves to something to keep from getting thrown off.
At least that is what I did.
I found a place where I could sit down and also time myself with the straps of
my life preserver.
Okay.
By now,
everyone was wet from the driving rain and the wind whistled and how old I
thought to myself,
is our misery ever going to end?
When daylight came,
I sort of wished it hadn't.
What I saw was enough to scare a person to death.
We were adrift in violence,
sees with 50 foot waves.
You had to look almost straight up to see their crest.
When they came rolling towards you,
they were much higher than the ship,
especially when the ship was in a trough.
So they had hit this mine.
Yeah,
the engine room was flooded.
There's still 200 miles from Okinawa,
so this is
the captain.
The captain comes on is like confident,
like don't worry,
we're only 200 miles from Okinawa and he says to himself,
Hey,
I can't swim 200 miles.
I don't know about you,
Kevin,
back to the book,
besides severely damaging the ship,
the exploding mine was responsible for the deaths of about 10 ex prisoners and
several sailors that were in the engine room.
The ex prisoners were on the deck when the mine went off the explosion slung
landing ladders that were hanging on the side of the ship up and over the
railing like lethal whips.
These men were apparently killed instantly.
These were the same ladders that we had used to board the ship just a few days
earlier.
I felt depressed and I'm sure that the other men felt the same.
These were men who were on their way home after they're terribly long and hard
or deal,
and now they were dead.
Yeah.
To get this far and still not make,
it was unbelievable.
The Japs finally got them after all with their floating mine.
Okay.
I couldn't help but think of the poor parents and families back home.
They had been notified that their son or husband or brother was on his way home
and you can imagine the joy that they felt now.
They had to be notified that they had been killed
on the way home.
Um,
yeah.
They eventually go from Okinawa to Manila and then from Manila they're waiting
for a ship to go back to the states.
One day I finally saw my name on a list pinned to a bulletin board as I was
leaving as one leaving by ship for the states on such and such a date before
long and he gets on the ship before long the last,
the tropical islands disappeared in the distance we are now well out in the open
ocean.
There was nothing to do but eat,
sleep and read and this would go on for several weeks.
My Body tingled in the dark.
When I thought about what the future might bring sitting out on the deck with a
cool breeze blowing and the ship gently rocking made me feel a little guilty for
having it.
So good.
Yeah,
goes on.
They sale.
One day we spotted land and before long we were going under the Golden Gate
Bridge and into San Francisco Bay.
We eventually doctored the same pier we had taken off almost four years earlier.
At the dock.
Many soldiers were met by their families and you could see the joy in their
faces as they tightly embraced each other.
They had been to war and survived.
Now they check into a hospital.
One of the first things that the doctor said when he saw me was,
you have hepatitis
a.
We were fed for large meals a day between meals.
Nurses brought around ice cream,
candy and cookies for anyone that was still hungry.
They were obviously trying to fatten us up before we went home.
Finally he gets on a hospital train car he has for San Antonio,
Texas,
and then from there he was finally given a pass to go home
and he's with a friend of his.
Before we got to Lafayette,
I talked my friend into staying overnight and Crowley so we could clean up and
be rested for our trip home.
The next day we spent the night at the rice hotel.
Next morning I decided to get a haircut,
so I went to a barber shop nearby.
The barber started talking about the boys that had left to go to war,
some of whom had been killed.
He then talked about about a family that lived near Mulatta that had two sons
killed and another missing in action.
Okay.
He said that the one missing in action later turned out to be a prisoner of war
of the Japanese.
I was shocked beyond belief,
belief,
and I know I turned pale because I was positive.
He was talking about me and my brothers even though he did not give names.
Yeah.
This news came as a complete surprise,
but I had begun to suspect something before.
Now in a letter or two that I sent home,
I inquired about Andrew and Steven
but never got any information concerning them.
When I received mail in return,
I thought maybe they had overlooked questions or at worst or at worst,
maybe they had been wounded in the war.
I knew that Steven was in the service but not Andrew.
You can imagine my grief when I found out they had both been killed
before long.
I decided to call my sister Eunice to see if she could come and get me into.
Of course,
she was overjoyed to hear my voice.
She said that she would be over as soon as she could before long she arrived in
some of her first words that she said were,
pat,
I'm afraid I have some bad news for you.
Pat was a nickname that my family calls me.
I knew what she was about to say,
so I stopped her and said,
I already know about my brothers.
I finally got to the farm.
My mother met me at the front gate.
She was crying,
which I expected,
and started to tell me about Andrew and Steven.
I told her I knew everything
and everything would be all right,
but she kept crying.
We hugged each other for awhile and finally I was able to shake hands with my
father.
He said one word,
Pat,
and I said,
one papa,
and that was it.
He was never much for talking,
but I knew that he was glad to see me back.
So after all that,
he comes home and finds out that both of his brothers had been killed.
His father says,
Hey,
if you want to stay here and work at the farm and hang out,
that's fine.
And he tells his dad,
no,
he's going to go to college and finish his degree in the Gi bill covers his cost
of his college
and he says there's not a great deal to do.
While home on leave.
I walked in the woods a lot,
visited our old swimming hole at the big cypress tree.
I thought of the fund we used to have
and especially the mudflats that were so exciting.
We were all grown up.
Now that is the ones who were still alive.
Okay.
Such a change in five and one half years.
I was given my discharge
on February 17th,
1946 I had been in the service for five and one half years and those are years.
I shall never forget.
When I was in the service,
I always felt so very young because everyone else was older than me.
Returning to college,
I felt just the opposite.
I felt so much older than most of my students and of course I was
okay.
One thing I never talked about wall in college.
It was my experience in the service.
I would tell new friends that I was a veteran and had served overseas,
but that was it.
I was still abiding by the militaries requests not to tell about your pow
experience to anyone.
I may not have had trouble keeping my pow experiences to myself after my return.
Okay.
But one aspect of the experiences I did have trouble with,
and that was my dreams at night,
almost every night when I fell asleep,
I found myself back in prison camp and I would think to myself and my dream.
How did this happen?
I was sure I had been freed.
It was heartbreaking to find that I was still a prisoner.
It was just the reverse of what I had experienced in prison camp when I always
dreamed I was free.
When I woke up during the war,
I found I was still a prisoner,
but at least when I woke up as a civilian,
I found that I was free.
As good as this felt,
it was still very disturbing mentally because these dreams lasted for about 10
years.
For the first few years I hated to go to sleep,
but luckily the dreams became less frequent.
Even now they are not completely gone.
This dream tells me that in the recesses of my mind,
I am still haunted by my participation and experiences during the Bataan death
march.
It is something that I will undoubtedly be there always.
Yeah.
But even though I may not be able to control my dreams,
I long ago learned to live with my life.
Yeah.
As though none of this had ever happened.
The dream that keeps coming back most often is one in which I find myself across
a large body of water.
I know that I must walk for miles and miles to return to where I want to be.
Okay.
In my mind,
I know I have made this long,
long walk before and I know how difficult and time consuming it will be
in my dream.
I feel completely dejected because I wonder what could have happened to get me
back to this place again.
Yeah.
But in my dream,
I start walking.
And I think that that right there,
well wraps up the book.
And I think that is a,
a very powerful message for everyone,
for everyone.
No matter what you face,
no matter how bad it is going to be,
when there is a challenge.
And by a challenge,
I mean Amy thing in life,
any,
any challenge,
anything that you're facing,
the only way to overcome the challenges that you face
is to start walking.
Take that step.
That is what James Bolek did
and the Bataan death march,
it was absolutely ruled a war.
Cold War crime after the war.
And the Japanese Lieutenant General Houma Masaharu who oversaw the march and
oversaw the atrocities that took place during the march,
he was put on trial and he was found guilty of war crimes and he was executed
April 3rd,
1946 just outside of Manila.
But James,
uh,
Bowlick lived,
he survived the death march.
He survived three and a half years in absolutely wretched conditions.
And
James Bullock survives today.
He's still alive and he lives in Louisiana still.
And as a matter of fact,
on the 25th of May of this year,
2018 James Bullock was awarded the Congressional Gold Medal,
the highest civilian award for the accomplishments that he achieved in his life
and that he has achieved in his life.
He's a retired geologist.
He's written 11 books,
including the one that I read from today,
a soldier's journal.
And actually the copy that I got,
which I got
from a used bookstore,
he's got a note,
he signed it and his signature has a note and the note says,
simply respect the flag,
respect the flag.
And I definitely recommend you pick up a copy of the book.
And I also recommend that you take his advice every day,
no matter what you are facing,
get up
and start walking.
Yeah.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles,
I guess at this point.
Okay.
Maybe since we're talking about walking you,
could you tell us how to walk?
Maybe don't walk down the path a little bit.
Little bit of an easier walk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Little bit that um,
there was another backs.
Yeah.
A few other books where this was like that,
where every,
every situation he kind of goes through.
You just get more and more exhaust,
like you're exhausted because you kind of think like,
okay,
it'll start to let up.
Yeah.
And then it's,
it's doesn't matter.
It's madness.
If you put this,
like if it's,
if you put this into a movie,
you wouldn't believe it.
It's a,
I'll know they're really going to have a storm over there.
You're gonna hit a mine.
Come on.
Like I'm not buying that.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
Yeah.
It literally,
does it sound like something like someone would try to put in a movie.
To me it just seemed like,
oh,
his journey was so hard.
Yeah.
It was a real one,
by the way.
Yeah.
And you kind of feel when he starts talking about like for some reason,
I don't know,
maybe it's,
cause I'm kind of hungry right now,
but when he's talking he's started men of feeling the stuff and then when he,
when he'd be like,
yeah,
when they switched.
So we're talking about a man that was lost 75 pounds of body weight.
Want to be,
he wasn't eating and you haven't eaten in four hours.
You're throwing that out there.
I've met comparing bro.
Compared,
I'm saying after I kind of felt,
I felt in this situation and I,
and I might want to edit to South Alabama.
Hey,
I will say this.
You know what I'm looking forward to tonight is I'm going to go,
first of all,
I've been traveling,
I am tired.
Sure.
And tonight I'm going to go enjoy my mattress and my bed.
Yeah.
And I'm gonna think about that when I'm crawling.
I got an,
I got a pretty nice bed.
It's nothing crazy,
but it's nice.
Better than the floor.
You know what a California king.
Yes I do.
That's the biggest bed you can get.
It's the longest yet eastern king is wider.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
Meet me and my wife spent a lot of time trying to determine California king
dangle and I'm going to get in that thing tonight.
We all leave that with the guest bed spread on it.
Yeah,
it is.
So you felt you were feeling this pain a little here.
A little bit extra to then when he was talking about like the floor and all this
stuff and then he finally got on that mattress that he hadn't been,
you know,
no mattresses for years.
I think if you compare,
if you compare anything that he literally,
anything in that book,
anything that he's talking about,
you can just say,
I have it good.
I don't care who you,
Oh yeah,
I got it.
So good.
I'm just in the living in the lap of complete luxury.
You have read it,
you know the part when they were like,
oh yeah,
and then they'd feed us,
uh,
cookies and candy bars or whatever.
Trying to fatten them up.
When you were saying that,
I was thinking tonight if I want to,
and I'm considering to steel right now,
by the way,
I can go to the store on the way home,
and just pick up as many candy bars as I want right now.
Just candy bars,
stakes,
ice cream.
You can pretty much any possible thing you could possibly imagine.
You can get within three,
within seven minutes of departing from this,
this podcast right now on your way to your California [inaudible],
California king bed and the sheets and you have the strength to put your
blankets.
That's cool too.
It's nice to be able to pull your blankets over yourself because you're not so
malnutrition when they and when the blankets are on you.
That's,
that's kind of Nice.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
you know,
cause you pain,
it doesn't like suffocate cause you're gonna break your ribs.
This one I'm like yeah bro.
Big Time and let me and yeah,
but you were feeling it though,
I think,
you know.
Definitely.
Okay.
Let me for them,
for the people out.
Definitely feeling it coheres.
Here's Jocko today.
By the way,
I witnessed his whole journey more or less as whole journey because I follow him
on Instagram.
So what three 50 recorded wake up.
So you probably woke up at,
at the very least,
45 three 45 okay,
so three 45 drink up.
I was in Denver and then,
yeah.
So I had to catch an early flight,
actually wasn't in Denver.
I was in boulder,
so I had to get a car from boulder lot for one hour.
One hour ahead.
I put one,
yeah,
it's one hour.
Okay,
so two 50 yeah.
You were taking away credit nonetheless to 50 wake up travel,
which like I said earlier,
to trick it.
Okay.
So travel from Colorado to San Diego.
To me that's the day already.
My Day done.
My work is done.
Let's face it.
I've got to recover from that.
That's me.
Can you come home?
You do what?
Oh,
oh,
on your way home.
You prep bit.
I've finished prep podcasts and then when I got home,
the first thing I did when I got home was finish the prep of the podcast.
I had about another hour to do.
Okay.
And you shift mentally to a workout.
Yeah.
Okay,
so,
so here's the thing where you know,
I'll work out.
Cool workout.
I've worked up after brought what I worked at the,
at the nightclubs.
I'd work out after a whole day at like three in the morning and I trained you to
get to before work,
you know?
Celltrak hey was the thing.
No.
You make that mental shift where you're like,
okay,
you wake up at 2:50 AM you travel?
To me,
mentally traveling just just kind of finishes me,
you know,
I got to kind of recover,
unless they have something lingering or something like that.
Okay.
There's that and then you still working,
by the way,
shift into workout mode still in the morning,
by the way.
Okay,
so workup mode,
you get your workout done,
which is,
we don't have to go into the detailed ever,
but it's a mini condition.
It's a conditioning circuit.
I pretty much took me,
I don't know yet,
but yeah,
basically the most solid little workout if personally.
Anyway,
I'm speaking for myself.
If I'm going to skip a workout on a day where I don't feel like it is going to
be one of those workouts,
one of those ones that you're doing,
like you know,
burpees and this and it's like the heart,
the junk ones,
they're painful anyway.
A little bit of get something.
Yeah.
And then so look,
it's exactly right.
And then you've got to Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Do bungee rounds.
Montreal.
Oh wait.
Over an hour of straight rolling.
Well,
I mean,
you know you have breaks between these two lights.
Yeah,
but it was an hour.
It's about an hour and 15 minutes.
Okay,
so that's a big deal.
That's way,
that's like maybe two or three times the amount of,
we'll say quote unquote normal rolling depending on who you are.
Okay.
And we've like Andy,
I saw Taylor here in Taylor.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
So it's not like you're buying with some that maybe you'll catch a new girl or
something that like this.
Okay,
here we go.
Still on chocolate scheduled,
by the way.
Okay.
And then now you got it.
Now you've got to do a podcast.
Okay.
So I'm trying to imagine your state of being in your mind.
And then when he said the part,
actually there's a bunch of parts when he's talking about on the ship and you
know the breeze and the,
the basically the rest parts.
I think you were feeling that.
What do you mean?
I was feeling it because you had that state,
you have that state of like you put it in a lot of work and now you know,
you're kind of on the backside to the recovery portion of the day.
Oh yeah.
So I think that part resonated with you is what I think.
Yeah,
I guess so.
All right.
Well there it is.
Boom.
See,
I know long explanation,
but still just saying,
you got to remember that even like,
like you just described my day,
but there's people out there that did five times more than what I did today.
There's,
there's,
uh,
there's people everywhere that are getting after it.
Super.
Yeah.
More than me.
Some people every single day,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
It's definitely true.
And it does bread this.
And that's how a lot of books like this men where the,
you know what Kinda got me fired up was Dan Bat Dan bats here and he and the
family and his and his wife.
And so damn bats,
a guy that's been like kind of in the game for since day one.
And He,
and,
and so I knew him from social media and as soon as I saw him,
he's like,
Hey,
I'm,
and I was like,
oh,
hey,
what's up man?
Yeah,
we're old school.
And,
but then,
you know,
him and his brother and,
and you know,
Dan was in the Marine Corps and now he's a,
he's a government official still.
He's still,
uh,
carries a gun for a living.
Right.
And,
and I was,
you know,
he was all just like,
he's like,
oh,
you're going to record right now.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he was pumped.
That gets me,
uh,
yeah,
I'm stoked when people are stoked.
He goes,
he was walking,
he was already covering a book.
Can you tell me?
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm coming to soldiers journal.
I go,
it's awesome.
It go.
It's about a guy on the Bataan death march cause I can't wait till Wednesday.
And I was like,
I'm going to go in there and testing.
So yeah.
Dan Bhat thanks for coming up.
And uh,
thanks for swinging by the gym.
You didn't come and get me to roll though unfortunately.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Cause he was on the,
he was doing,
he was doing Nogi I was doing the [inaudible] the key daggy.
Yeah.
Interesting.
But is that,
I mean,
I know,
we know and you know,
so as like,
okay,
I'm Dan Bet I'm coming in.
I see Jack for the first time.
He's over there rolling with NBN Taylor,
by the way.
And I'm over here doing Nogi a little bit early in in the Jiu Jitsu career.
Jack Lew,
their training hardcore.
Do I walk over there and try to roll with Jocko?
That's the question.
Yeah,
well,
some people do,
some people don't.
For us,
like yeah.
If I were to ask you that,
you'd be like,
yeah,
come wrong.
But like I said,
if I'm dead bad,
it's my first time at victory.
I see you over there.
Do I do that?
Yeah,
maybe I overestimated the,
I feel like I know him pretty well.
He probably feels like he knows us real well.
W he came up,
he was like my other friend Anthony,
he was like,
Oh yeah,
that guy,
he's,
he's the one farm buffalo,
um,
Jiu Jitsu and all this stuff.
His name is Dan.
I was like,
oh yeah,
cool Dan.
I meet him.
I'll take,
Hey Dan,
cause I didn't draw,
I didn't make the connection then stand back,
stand back.
Because we all know none.
Dan back from it,
from the beginning because I don't,
for whatever,
maybe I'm not looking at his picture close enough or whatever.
But um,
yeah,
when you were like,
Dan Bet.
I was like,
ah,
this is getting better.
And then I'm like cruising with them,
you know,
damn bat is on the path but still on the way on the path.
He's away on the path.
Big Time.
And so are we.
And then we can talk about some stuff to help support the path and people's
path.
All right,
first one gonna talk about origin.
So origin.
Origin is the company,
the company.
This is where you get your gear when you're introduced to [inaudible].
Just to real quick.
So one,
you take Jujitsu,
you need a geek cause you're doing g and Nogi.
Yes.
That's a good idea.
I don't what's going to be mad at you if you just Dukie or if you just do know
geek,
everyone's going to be mad at you or no one's going to be mad at you,
but as a strong recommendation to both.
So when you do both,
you can need a gate origins.
This is why you get an origin.
Get no other gate.
Don't get any more than any other gay.
You don't have to.
No.
I have other geese from before or while they're in my laundry room in the
factory.
I got scolded from my wife.
Why are those keys up there?
They'd been up there for your wife's in the game.
She's said,
get rid of them.
They're not going to wear them.
They're not welcome.
You're legitimately not going to wear them.
Legitimately not going to want.
There's no point to have them.
Yeah,
it's true.
Goodwill.
Yeah.
Goodwill or even you don't bring it to this,
I don't know,
bring it to your academy and then they can use those as loaner piece.
Exactly.
Right.
Know,
so and rational these loaner gates too.
That is true.
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
in the meantime before people get an origin.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
But yeah,
all made in America from the beginnings of the birth of the Geek is their birth
of Vicki.
Not really.
Not really the will.
The cotton is grown in America.
How about that?
That's how early on the main in America situation commences,
um,
all made in America and by Pete and his team who know about Jujitsu,
black belt in Jujitsu in the game of Jujitsu from day one.
So he knows all about and make the connection.
That's why,
that's why they're the best geese overall.
Right there.
Boom.
That's it.
They also make rash guards as well.
So [inaudible] no geek,
boom,
key rash guard,
rash guards,
and you can get all kinds of stuff on there too.
Tee shirts.
Um,
they may have shorts.
Now,
do you ever pair of those shorts yet?
Broad?
No,
I don't.
I don't either,
but I'm going to get what I'm just,
I was gonna like send both of them a text group,
text a group to be like,
Hey,
I'm looking outside the door.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Oh,
I'm getting other male,
no shorts.
But then again,
the origin,
the emerging camps coming up,
I'm sure it's a thing where the boom and actually that makes more sense.
Less packing there.
What I'm saying,
I'm not happy about it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm with you on that one.
Not happy but some,
yeah.
Some other stuff than just Jujitsu stuff.
Yes.
Did you just say it'd be on dance and really the shorts are starting to get into
like,
cause they're not even,
they're not for training.
There's just for straight up wearing.
Yeah.
Just for wearing around.
Plus there's supplements on there too.
Uh,
we got joint warfare,
which is good for your joints.
Sure.
We got Krill oil,
which is also good for your joints.
Was that the,
was that the supplement that pushed you over the edge when you mean over the
edge that got you to start using software?
That's Krill oil.
Yes.
Okay.
That was like a,
what do you call it?
It was like a gateway supplement.
Anyways,
what,
I dunno if that in and of itself was the gateway.
So I think you were essentially the influence gateway,
uh,
entity,
if you will.
But that was the one where you,
when you started taking it and you were like,
oh,
this actually works and so I'm going to continue.
And then then when I was saying,
you know what,
I got something called jungle warfare and then you're like,
I'm gonna start cracking down so that you got your arm healed up and now you're
a believer.
And the thing about both of those things is kid glucosamine Chondroitin is in
joint warfare,
right?
It has other good stuff.
But that was kind of human he has in there,
which is actually as big of a deal as the other two that you just mentioned.
Yeah.
As it turns out,
I didn't know this at the time.
So you're like,
yeah,
joint warfare,
Krill oil,
all this stuff.
And these are things that I heard about before and I was like,
cool.
But you know,
hey man,
I don't care.
I don't need to take supplements.
You just,
you know,
eat right and all this stuff.
We wouldn't have multiple tone,
joint warfare.
We've got discipline,
which is good for just good for mission life mission getting after it.
Yeah.
Brian was explaining to me that it helps you a look,
I'm going to get the terminology wrong,
but because I'm doing this off of memory,
but it's like adaptive gins or something.
Basically it helps you manage any stress that comes to you look at,
you see what I'm saying?
Like it helps you manage stress and that goes for like physical and mental
stress.
So remember when everyone else is telling you?
Yeah,
like last time with time with Dina,
would everyone else saying when I took the three scoops I felt like I could just
deal with stuff I like my patients was in the house,
the adaptogens were in the house.
So Brian totally explained it.
So I was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
So what I'm saying,
see that's a little soft.
I think that that's a little subtle thing that,
you know how it's like,
yeah,
I can remember where is quicker and like all this stuff,
good man,
good.
And I did have the adaptive,
I'm not saying I'd rather or not right.
I'm saying that's part that I think anyway,
we all might kind of disregard.
You know,
it's basically the opposite of having,
you know,
when you're like,
what do you call it when you're irritable,
you know that,
okay,
so consider when you're irritable.
Not,
I'm not going to say you're going to behave a certain way.
Some people do when they're irritable,
they're shorter,
they're shorter temper.
They,
you know,
when things don't go their way,
I consider that to be a weakness.
Yes.
Okay.
So consider that to be weak.
So consider that.
Like when I snapped it somewhere,
which I,
I like rarely snap someone because I considered,
I don't know,
when I started thinking that way,
like,
hey,
just snapping at someone is just when I,
if I snap at you bro,
there's,
you did some really jacked up or maybe you're just super duper irritable in
general.
I think you were at doe.
I'm literally sitting here trying to figure out the last time I felt
legitimately we,
you know what,
it'll be something.
It'll,
you know what,
you know what bothers me.
It bothers me if I'm trying to work and people want to talk to me about stuff.
So this is more of a home life scenario and normally I schedule my situations
that everyone's asleep or I'm separated,
but sometimes people want to interact and,
and when I'm doing my work,
you know,
and you kind of have with my wife where you know,
you've seen the movie the shining,
right?
Yes sir.
I'll be,
I'll be sitting there and I'll be working.
I'm like,
when you hear this,
when you hear that it means I am typing.
That is my type writer and that means I'm trying to work.
And if you here before king,
they don't,
and she starts laughing.
So I throw a little Jack Nicholson and she realizes that I'm trying to do what I
do.
Well,
I will say that that's podcast prep books,
whatever fully you get down and they dig it.
But that's not really you snapping though is nothing like on a friendly version
of saying,
hey,
it is my way of of let's say,
projecting my frustration into a good positive humorous thing that releases the
tension and gets the message across.
Remember earlier today we were talking about getting the message across without
doing collateral damage.
If that's what I'm talking about.
Oh,
I just throw on a little bit of that here.
This,
well the actually that's good because men,
let's talk,
I don't want to deviate too much,
but do you mean we're talking about completely deviated so far there's not even,
I don't remember where we came from.
It has to do with getting the message across,
right?
You can have the greatest info in the world,
the most important info in the world,
but if you can't get across,
right?
So it's like,
yeah man in Pour,
super important potentially.
But here's the thing about information and what you say and how you say it's
like all this,
it's good.
It has to land,
you know,
so you can start throwing out info in it,
but if it doesn't land,
you might as well not have said nothing.
Be appended.
Whatever you were talking about earlier with the discipline you were talking
about.
Oh yeah,
that adaptogens.
That's a whole nother thing right now we'll go back to the data that you were
talking about.
You being in all this stuff.
Okay.
I'll go actually back to the point.
Back to the point.
Okay,
so the adaptogens,
it's the opposite of being irritable.
That's what I felt.
And I think when we think about like discipline and you know,
could neutral bay health,
brain health,
all this stuff we think about like remembering words.
I mean sharper and quicker,
but we don't think about like the opposite of being irritable.
I don't know if there's,
is there a word for the opposite of irritable?
Because it's not the kind of,
oh like it's just,
okay,
I'm cruising.
It's not that feeling.
It's more like cruising.
No.
Speaking of information,
why don't you give us some information about molex or we can move on.
Okay,
well take the don't,
don't,
don't slip on the discipline anyway.
Okay.
Milk.
Here's mom cause you'll be the opposite of irritable.
That's a good tagline.
We should use that.
I was sort of irritable.
You have met and it works.
It worked for me.
Keep in mind when you're irritable,
that's not a good feeling.
Nope.
Most of us,
if we don't get like you know,
sleep or sometimes,
well I guess it depends on who you are,
but some people when they get hangry,
that's what that is.
Still it is not a good feeling.
You feel the opposite of that is a good feeling.
So what I'm saying?
Check just simple math anywhere.
Milk.
Okay.
If you want some additional protein,
this is a good way to get it.
Can you imagine?
You remember how he was talking about if he had seen movies while he was in
prison camp,
you would have tried to break out and go yeah.
If you were in that situation and you had had Mulkey before,
that would be our,
well because you'd be thinking about not only how big it is and how good it is.
How tasty it is.
It's like you're stuck there.
You can't have it.
That happened to me yesterday when I was on my trip.
Oh Dang.
He didn't bring them up.
I didn't bring Moke and I need to figure that situation out a little bit better,
but because that's just an,
I do.
I do some,
I've branched out a little bit.
I normally always did two scoops of Mulkin,
big glass of milk.
And now I'm kind of doing little hitters.
Hitters.
Well there's still,
there's still wonderful scoop.
I haven't gone below.
I haven't done just like a straight up shot,
but I've been doing little hitters.
Just one,
just one scoop.
And what's the philosophy behind the,
you know,
like what,
why?
Cause I,
I'm so full when I get done with Moke like this morning when I got home,
since I didn't have more on my trip,
when I got home,
before I started recording,
before I started prep prepping for the podcast,
I had a little hitter of milk,
which I,
by the way,
I took a hitter,
that whole concept of using the word hitter from the field Vaughn.
So,
yeah,
I think he uses it for everything.
Like things can just be a hit or I have a little hit or what little one scoop
hit her head out.
That's what I hear.
Boom.
There you go.
No,
I don't want to say that.
The odd.
So it's the opposite.
There's something you have to be careful of.
If you think in the future,
you may be completely in a situation where you can't have milk.
Maybe it's better to never have it.
So you're going to have to always think about it forever.
You can't,
you don't know.
It's just,
yeah,
I'm going the opposite direction.
I'm going,
I'm making them bigger.
Just bigger.
Like last.
It was weird.
So I went to sleep kind of early,
which is like I'm not,
you know,
some people that they prefer to go sleep hungry cause it's like,
whatever their philosophy is,
I'd prefer not to go sleep hungry.
So I ate,
I ate dinner and then I stay up a couple of hours and I'm like,
oh I either eat right now when I'm not really hungry or risk being hungry at
some point.
Very soon.
So what I did do well in prison,
that would not work out for me for sure.
And the less I take the milk,
three scoops.
Oh God.
Peanut butter,
man.
I don't know why.
I do know what to peanut butter scope to the men total double dip.
You know you're going crazy.
Yeah.
The thing is,
I know how like the sound of that test,
but it's good for DJ stuff sounds.
It's going to sound good nonetheless.
But I've been doing it and it's the kind where it's like what?
I already know how it tastes.
Like why would I not even do that?
Okay.
I've said it and you actually,
I said don't cross the streams like Ghostbusters.
And you said that's how they won.
Yes.
So maybe you got across the peanut butter and the men,
I don't know.
I don't even think I'm going to try it.
That's up to you.
And maybe it's one of those things that if I try it then I'll have to carry
around both types all the time for the rest of my life.
So you pour,
you mix them up.
Oh Man.
Right.
That's up to you anyway.
Hey Mark,
how you want a Moke?
Moke up bulk up.
That's good.
Right?
That rhymes uncle.
Anyways,
so,
so like,
so I hit it.
It's a big,
you know,
you got to hit her.
I hit it.
So technically it maybe it was a hit her,
but it was huge.
Huge theater or you got one of those big hills pounded it.
No problem.
I'll just smoke.
Is going to get consumed at the immersion camp you think?
I think it's going to be well considered myself alone.
I mean man,
I'm on the train big time.
So that's every day.
Yeah.
How many scoops while we're at emerging camp,
how many scoops of Moke will you consumed per day?
Well,
pretty,
I dunno,
I just say six minimum because as we can,
well you figured I'm just saying crazy.
Well you know,
I as much as just as good on six two scoops for one,
two,
three I could see maybe doing for,
for me maybe two in the morning,
maybe two in the afternoon,
maybe.
Maybe have a one more hit her in the middle somewhere.
Nonetheless,
that small,
good,
good protein and it tastes good.
See that's the thing.
Well,
if he'd do it as like someone who was texting me,
Oh can you do it as a meal replacement?
Can you do [inaudible] and the day before I got that text,
Pete was saying,
I said something,
I forget what it was.
And he said,
ha ha yeah,
you can use it as a meal replacement breakfast.
I think that's one of the reasons why I was Dixie beat.
Um,
and then so yeah,
so when you do it as a meal replacement,
it's like it's not the meal,
it's like a dessert as a meal replacement.
Both.
See what I'm saying?
It's just like the treat you look forward to them.
Unless it's good to get all this@originmain.com this,
we can get all this stuff.
Cool website.
Sure.
I would talk about the emerging camp,
but it sold out.
Here's the thing too.
I was talking to Andy Berke,
not Dave Burke.
Good deal Dave.
Not good deal.
David.
Andy Berke.
No relation.
And we were talking about like,
okay,
so it's one thing to be like,
hey,
we're getting kind of full,
we'll just get more mats.
But then we're now we're talking about the camp being full so it's we're,
we're full,
we're filled up,
can't do it unless maybe like you bring your tent or something like that maybe
nonetheless sold out.
So yeah,
maybe next year.
There it is.
All origin stuff.
Good way to support as well.
Shifting gears,
Jocko was a store,
it's called Jocko store.
So you go to Jocko store.com.
This is where you can get shirts,
hoodies,
tank tops,
some rash guards,
more rash guards.
Um,
good way to support it.
Like I said,
this is where a,
if you want to represent discipline equals freedom.
Just the general concepts and how should I say,
uh,
philosophies of the game.
Overall def core.
Yeah,
just overall.
Just overall if you want to represent,
that's where you get it.
Jocko.
store.com got some new designs on there.
I was,
I was going to send out like an email to everybody that did sign up for the
email.
This,
it's been a few months,
so I might as well,
so I'll probably send out something just to indicate,
hey,
we got some new stuff.
Boom.
There it is.
Yeah.
If boom.
Cause a lot of times it's like,
it's not like people are just going to be going chocolate store every day.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
You know?
No,
there's no reason to do that when you don't put new stuff up very often.
So how would they do that?
We'll just say this.
No,
uh,
strong reason to do it.
So Hey,
I'll send the email.
Boom,
let them know.
Anyway.
Yeah.
TACO store.com.
Good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
I know,
seems obvious,
but I think it is obvious it's obvious guys,
but just to let you know if they're listening right now.
Yeah,
they subscribed.
that's true.
And when you're subscribing to that,
also there's a warrior kid podcast.
So if you got kids between the ages of four and 44,
they can get something out of the warrior can podcast and you can subscribe to
that.
You can also subscribe to Youtube.
And we deal,
we're discussing today making some,
some these are,
these are not even these are in different situation.
What I briefed you on today about what we're going to make.
Those are a different thing.
There are a different thing.
There are different,
they're not enhanced videos.
They're not excerpts.
Different specific thing for specific
lessons learned specifically topics that I've discovered that I need to cover
and I think the best way to cover them is through the video medium.
So we're gonna do that.
And there will be specific to youtube actually they will be very specific to
youtube because they're both involve graphics.
Uh,
you know,
they they involve,
yeah,
me explaining something.
Utilizing graphics.
Yeah.
What the right word.
Graphics for what I was doing charts,
charts,
diagrams,
dive if you will.
But this is verse.
Yeah.
And this is,
it was funny.
It's like you just say it like,
it's like,
yeah,
it'll be a cool addition to the thing.
This like what you,
what we talked about will you explained is if I would've known this,
it's almost like the secret to life
is not joke.
No,
I know.
I know it's so we'll put it to,
we get this,
this means we're gonna have to put it together.
Maybe we could do,
could we do it while we're in Maine or something?
Yeah,
it does knock it.
I don't want to,
I don't want to get crazy with it.
I just want to put the word out there.
I need a dry erase board.
I need to explain it.
I'll think through it a couple times and then I'll put it out there because it
will help.
It will definitely help fully both those,
both those topics.
There's two topics that need to come out and I'll discuss both of them.
We'll put it on the youtube and then,
and then people can get them.
So subscribe to the Youtube Channel for that it the channel's called Jocko
podcast.
And
also when I said subscribe,
that's to the audio.
So you do this video.
The audio is like iTunes,
stitcher,
Google play or wherever you listen to podcasts.
But I know it seems obvious,
but it might smell it.
Throw it in there just in case.
Maybe someone's new to podcasting in general.
Okay.
You just never know.
I'm just going to be quiet.
It's just a fun one.
Also also on it,
so on it.com/jocko by the way,
you get 10% off of what?
What do we get?
10 is so where if you want to vary up your workout,
I know I said it before,
but very will be work out kettlebell stuff,
a battle ropes stuff.
I got some rings.
Are you bringing your rings to me?
Yes.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm bringing mine.
Cool.
This is where you get it on.com/jocko really good stuff on there.
Good Info as well.
So if you're new to certain types of workouts,
get the info first.
You can enter it,
you can enter into that workout situation educated,
keep yourself safe and you know,
boom.
Get the results without all that injuries.
You see what I'm saying?
Also,
we made a spoken word,
spoken word album,
album with tracks and it's,
it's me actually.
We made it,
but it's me talking and it's me just telling you not to be weak today,
but to go do and what you're supposed to do.
And we're going to make another one of those working on it now,
gathering the topics.
So if you have topics for psychological warfare,
then you can put them on the social media thing and I'll get them,
we will assess if they are important topics or if they're important topics.
Either way.
Yes,
we'll figure it out.
So basically if you're struggling,
not struggling,
but yeah,
if you're like kind of struggling something,
you'd have moments of weakness.
What is it?
What scenario are you in?
What are you week with?
My sister used to say a white rice is like her weakness.
Oh,
assume saying white.
Right.
So I gotta make a psychological warfare that says the white rice that you're
looking at right now,
put it today.
If she was going to get 100% sugar once it enters your stomach,
walk away,
walk away from the white rice.
Now actually that's why that kind of would,
cause she said late at night,
this was long time ago by the way.
She said late at night.
So yeah,
she were to play it and you're like,
walk away,
swipe.
She'd be walking away.
That's all it is.
Fee.
That's how it starts.
Psychological warfare.
It's available on Itunes,
Google play,
MP,
three platforms,
blah,
blah.
Jocko white tea that you can get in a can or you can get it in a tea bag and you
can get both those from Amazon.
That's where they're at.
So if you want to be able to deadlift no less than 8,000 pounds,
100% guaranteed,
all you have to do is drink Jocko white tea.
You don't have to work out even,
you don't even have to lift weights.
You just drink it and then you can deadlift 8,000 pounds.
Don't worry.
It's no problem.
Uh,
books.
I wrote some books,
wrote some kid books,
actually where the word kit,
that's the first one and way of the w is the second.
Okay.
The second one is Mark's mission,
but is it called the way of the word your kid?
I'm not sure.
Let's look at the cover.
It does say way of the warrior kid marks mission.
So existence where the warrior King Mark's mission.
Yeah.
I think I should put a big one and two on them.
So that it's more clear.
The next book,
the next one that comes out,
April say three on it.
Yeah,
good idea.
Because they are kind of essentially the whole story and even the lessons by the
way,
are they build a lodge for sure.
See what I'm saying?
So like the first one,
the lessons and the struggles and the problems with whatever our nine year old
problems right now.
I mean give or take,
you know,
there like a certain age,
10 year old times problems the next and then they,
they get a little bit more sophisticated,
you know,
excellent.
More and more.
So it's kind of chronological and not to mention the story as well.
So it makes make sense.
You don't want to do it that way.
And that's if you want your kids to actually get after it straight up.
I get the best feedback from those books.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I could see why.
I mean shoot,
I'm one of those people who's giving you the feedback very well.
Very well done.
Is it fair as a book,
what do you,
what do you call critic?
Critic?
Who has
read a book before,
you know,
hey,
it's good.
It's a good book.
I have it as like just an a running theme.
Like I just keep reading the book.
It just keep reading both of them.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
That's how so it becomes the ethos.
That's why your daughter,
which I primarily see your daughter more.
She's like,
you know,
she gets after it.
She uh,
she does get it after.
It does.
It's constant work.
Don't matter of course is big health,
huge help.
Also discipline equals freedom field manual.
Who would've thought that that book would be popular?
That people would be into it.
That's what's cool.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think most people don't think there's people that really want to
get after it.
Yeah.
And they do and they don't know how.
When you think about it,
it's gonna start to,
it kind of makes sense really when you just like,
okay,
so field manual,
right.
You have a manual,
a manual.
Cause that's a lot of times that's why people don't do stuff because I don't
know how to do it.
They don't know.
And if I do certain
then I've got to look into it.
Then I keep looking into,
I wish they just had a manual.
I wish I had a manual for life.
How about that?
I wish I had a manual for parenting,
which had a manual for life.
I had always had a manual for,
you know,
a bunch of other stuff,
but if you want like one kid after it,
whatever you want to call it,
right?
You've got a manual,
you want to stay disciplined and you want freedom directly from the discipline.
Boom.
You got a manual right here.
There you go.
Also,
extreme ownership,
which is the first book that I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
It takes the combat principles that we learned on the battlefield and teaches
you and shows you how you can apply them to your business and your life and then
we got a follow on book to that coming out September 25th the dichotomy of
leadership,
you can preorder it right now so that way the publishers who are pessimistic,
that's,
that's how publishers are.
They're just pessimistic because for them they don't really care.
If you get,
if you don't get the book right when it comes out,
they're going to make their their money either way.
But when you,
when the book comes out and you order it the day it comes out and then it takes
nine days to get to you cause you,
cause they had to reprint them cause they ran out.
But I guess I shouldn't say because they're conservative,
they're constant.
There'd been all conservative knowing him,
we're just not sure and we don't want to spend the money on money on storage if
these things and then you're going to have to wait to get your copy.
Just don't do that.
You can preorder it and Lafe and I just did a podcast on what it's about.
That's podcast number one 38 if you haven't heard that one yet.
Also speaking of life,
speaking of me,
we have a leadership consulting company and is not just me and life.
It's also JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran and also Mike Cirelli and we come to your company and we'll help
you with your leadership.
We solve problems through leadership.
Also,
if you want one of us to just come speak at your company,
don't call a speaking agency.
Yeah,
you don't need to call a speaking agency.
You don't need to call cool speakers.com no,
go to echelon front.com and and get the information there.
Give the give the info and that's how you get to us.
Call me by the way or email me and then you pass it on national on front
influence you like get a little little,
little.
You like to get in the game info national on front.com if you want to just email
straight.
Also the muster zero zero six San Francisco,
California 17th and 18th it's probably going to sell out pretty soon.
The registration for that is it extreme ownership.com and also there's
registration for the roll call roll call zero zero one which is for current
uniformed personnel,
so military law enforcement,
border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
other first responders.
We put together the roll call because you lead in dynamic situations.
We want to do something a little bit cheaper,
a little bit shorter so you could get to it.
It's September 21st Dallas,
Texas and come on down to that.
Finally we have GF,
Overwatch connecting Spec ops and combat aviation folks from the military to
companies that need leaders,
need tested leaders.
So we've got great leaders out there that we know from our communities and now
we've got companies that we know from echelon front and we are bringing them
together.
So e f overwatch.com if you want to,
if you're either someone that wants to hire a bad ass leader or if you're a bad
ass leader that is retiring or getting out from your military service,
get on there and fill out that information
and until we do see you at the muster or at the roll call or at the immersion
camp,
if you want to cruise with us kind of hard on the interwebs.
We are there.
We are on Instagram,
Twitter,
and on that face we'll keep people echo,
is that Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally,
thanks to all the military personnel that are listening as you defend our great
nation from threats around the world.
Thank you for standing the watch and here in America to the police,
to law enforcement,
to firefighters,
to border patrol paramedics,
first responders,
thanks to you all as well for standing the watch here at home and keeping us
safe.
And thanks to everyone for listening and supporting.
And I know sometimes it can be hard to listen to stories from atrocities like
the Bataan death march.
I know that,
but in listening,
remember,
remember that evil does exist.
Remember those that died standing up against that evil.
And remember that even in the most wretched times when you face darkness
yourself,
no matter how bad things get,
remember,
remember not to stop.
Remember not to pause.
Remember not to hesitate.
Remember to put one foot in front of the other.
Take that first step
and start walking.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.